according so as chair of the house Edna
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
personent to executive order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any Bill referred to the
committee please note there's no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
cont temporaneous during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if invited
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting should call call
271-3600 or email HCS ledge. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by roll call vote we'll start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their pres
please also State whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to no
all
representative legro present in the room
representative Bailey present in the
fellows representative
[Music]
fellows not yet representative
representative
[Music]
goalie here at home and my wife is in
the other
room representa
BR here in my office at home
JY representative
I'll be Mobile today in nashille and I
am
alone representative leus pres in the
committee room representative McGuire
present in the committee room
representative OB
nsha representative Pearson presid in
the committee room representative Roy
representative
Santo president in the committee room
Schmid representative
Schmid sorry I unmute myself I'm
president in my home office in do and
I'm
alone representative
sh present at my home in pem Al
representative
Schultz presid in conquered and my
husband will be in and out of the room
clerk is present in the room
representative
yakovich present at home alone in the
room and we will try again for
representative
fellows and representative
Judy 17
pres thank you representative Zite so
I'm opening the hearing on Senate Bill 3
three and I first call Senator Waters
who the prime
sponsor uh thank you madam chair and uh
members of the committee for the record
I'm Senator David Waters from District 4
and I'm introducing Senate Bill
33 this bill will provide municipalities
and Native American tribal
Representatives with a procedure to
restore historically accurate and
documented names to geographical
features and sites it is entirely
enabling legisl ation i' like to speak
briefly as to um why this is necessary
and how naming is actually uh done in
New Hampshire and in United States uh
naming is governed by the United States
Council on Geographic names Authority
through its United States board on
Geographic names they have the final say
each state has a representative to the
board for New Hampshire that's Ken
gallager and we have a New Hampshire
Geographic uh names
Authority now of course the municipality
can do some naming of streets and things
um but for any name to be officially
recognized and appear on maps it needs
to go to the
board I want to note that some naming
powers in New Hampshire are reserved to
the state legislature in statute
mountains and rivers that pass through
more than one
municipality are governed by separate
state statutory Authority and this bill
has no effect whatsoever on that
Authority well why do this um
increasingly there is an interest in
municipalities and among Native American
tribal groups in restoring historical
names and why do we need the
bill well in New Hampshire uh has no
federally
recognized uh
tribes uh if we had a federally
recognized tribe the United States board
is required to consult with it so we do
need a process to ensure that Native
American tribal groups have the
authority to review and work with
municipalities who want to bring forward
proposals for
names concern about this uh nationally
is growing uh it was raised in a very
influential article last week last year
in Indian Country uh news and I was on a
call late last year um with national
Native American
leaders and I asked Raina theel who uh
was the head of tribal government issues
in a previous administration and
currently is the tribal liaison and
adviser for the Biden Administration
about you know what what to do in a
state that doesn't have federally
recognized tribes and she felt there
really did need to be a state uh
process I took the prepared uh Bill
language to the New Hampshire Commission
on Native American American fairs and to
others and attempted to address uh
concerns during the Senate process based
on their advice I did see the letter uh
yesterday which you received from uh the
commission on Native American Affairs uh
raising a couple of uh remaining issues
and so um when I saw that letter um I I
wrote an amendment uh which addresses
completely addresses completely the
concerns raised by inserting their
proposed language into the bill now I
sent committee members a uh version of
that revised bill um and maybe you have
that but if you have the uh original
language passed by the Senate and I I
should mention it came out of um the
senate committee five to zero and then
23 to1 on the four of the of the Senate
I'll just um you know if you have that
earlier version I will uh just make the
references to the Future changes that
are there so the way the bill um works
is first you'll see some findings which
basically repeats current language in
statute around the establishment of the
uh n Commission on Native American
Affairs um but it adds therefore the
general court finds that Native American
place names are a rich Legacy that ought
to be valued and visible and as such the
general
court uh local and state initiatives to
restore and assign and here's that key
phrase that the commission wanted
historically accurate and documented
abnaki names to places and
features um so then the bill read to US
senator we're all literate and on this
committee I appreciate that and I
certainly know you
are um the next portion of the
bill um assigns authority to the Native
American to the commission Native
American Affairs uh to have the
authority to review the recommendations
for
municipalities uh and um when requested
they might assist the
municipality in determining the
historically accurate and documented
names um I put that um when requested
there because the commission pointed out
that it it really has no staff and it's
a volunteer commission so that it didn't
feel that it needed it should be um
burdened with the necessity of doing all
the research and so forth um they may
decide to take some of that on but uh
here it really is they have the
authority to review the research that
has been brought forward uh by um by
municipality and then you'll see U both
for towns and for um cities uh the same
kind of language that if a town consults
with the commission Native American
Affairs and
informs other uh appropriate groups um
such as historical resource
then there is a list of um Native
American organizations uh consultation
list that the the Hampshire division of
historical resources has and that those
everybody on that list ought to be
informed as well and uh the point of
that is that there are some groups that
may not at a given moment be represented
on the uh on on the commission and then
um I think importantly in either case
that any proposal uh for historically
accurate and documented abnaki names um
needs to go to a vote needs to go to a
vote of the town and uh then it can be
submitted um to the New Hampshire
Geographic names Authority uh and then
onward onward uh from there uh so it
does it for both of the cities and the
and the towns and then um finally it
makes it uh clear explicitly that this
function uh is something for the um
Geographic naming Authority in the State
uh that they they do have this function
um to receive these requests and then to
pass them along um so uh as I said I'm
I'm very grateful to the guidance of the
commission on Native American Affairs
and attempting to address every concern
that they raised and grateful to the
advice and support of of others whom
you'll be hearing from and uh I think
it's a good step for New Hampshire to
give this enabling legislation to the um
municipalities to assert The Authority
that the uh commission has over the
process and I I really hope it' be a
good educational opportunity to promote
interest in New Hampshire's history and
thank you thank you madam
chair thank you Senator are there any
committee uh representative o looks like
is trying to
L thank you uh Madam chair I probably
should use the hand instead of the real
hand uh but uh thank you and Senator
thank you for taking the question uh I
think members of this committee have
been contacted by other members of the a
abanaki tribe that may not uh seem so
enthused with your support and coming
from uh the transportation committee
we've had similar circumstance ances
particularly with uh things such as uh
license plates when uh veterans uh group
organizations did not totally agree uh
one and it's particularly shameful when
we see stuff like that where it's
well-intentioned one group comes up with
one particular concept and another group
does not agree and it seems like you get
to t uh Cat by the tail on this
particular issue uh so uh are you
Unified my question is directly are you
unified in this front by the a abanaki
nation on this particular issue well
thank you for your question uh
representative and um let me just say I
never would uh suppose you know propose
to speak for Native American groups um
they speak for themselves I was very
very deeply involved in the uh Bill to
establish the the uh commission Native
American Affairs um I was was at the
University of New Hampshire for decades
the uh Native American Graves protection
repatriation act officer so I I've had
um with with great respect a lot of uh
interaction with the uh Native uh
community and um you know it is their it
is their voice I would say that that I I
listen very carefully and um I that's
why I wrote the amendment because I I
saw the letter that came from the
commission that raised the two issues
about making sure historically accurate
and documented and then wanting to Ure
that the commission had Authority here
and that proper information would be
given and potentially consultation with
any group may agree or disagree and um
so I I think I wouldn't expect
unanimity but I think that what the bill
now does is it has explicitly addressed
every issue that has been been raised
and um it's just an opportunity to make
a process work I mean here it is and um
it's a process it's enabling um some
municipalities interested in doing this
and so um now we'd have a a process that
would I think work for the the state but
um again finally whether I've been
entirely successful is is is not for me
to
say thank you Senator thank you Madam
chair all right representative Roy thank
you madam chair thank you for taking my
question Senator could you just um just
because I'm really new to this bill and
the concepts it proposes could you walk
me through a a hypothetical scenario of
this bill in action like what what
someone would do what can you just help
me out with that what it would look like
oh sure and thanks for your question
representative um so there's an awful
lot of historical research search and
knowledge about Native American place
names I mean certainly we've got some
now don't we wnab basaki right coo River
and do um and you know our maps and our
Landscapes uh reflect a lot of that a
lot of that history but there are many
other sites um that we we do uh have
have names for and um so a uh group May
um be interested in a municipality uh
having done some research on place names
historically in the community and it may
be that a Native American tribal group
in a region is interested in working
with the community so um let's say it's
it's a it's a it's a great geographic
feature A Gathering Place was an
encampment or um a spring or um a trail
or other other feature that there is
documented so it would bring It Forward
it do the research uh it would go to the
Native American uh the commission Native
American Affairs and say this is this is
what we are interested in um we need you
to review the research to ensure that
this is historically documented um and
and accurate which is important um and
uh then it would go back to the town and
the town would have to or municipality
would have to have a vote of the
governing body that they wanted to do
this um in in that process also other
folks would be informed that the
municipality was thinking about this and
here is their research that informing
could I think be handled through the um
division of historical resources because
they are the liaison they have the the
the contact list that they they already
work with on things like um you know if
there's a highway project and they find
a grave site or something so they they
have they have that list already um and
then if the town body votes to do this
it would be forwarded on to Ken
Gallagher um and then they they're the
body that when anything comes out of a
state can put it on to the the national
board so I mean that's kind of how
things are done now we do some naming
and renaming all the time and uh um this
is just developing a process that makes
sure that we get accurate names and that
the Native American tribal groups in the
commission you know have the appropriate
authority over
it follow up thank you um that that a
lot um quick follow-ups um first would
uh town be able to change a name to
something with just the vote of a
governing body without putting it to the
voters and second of all is it would
this enable towns to actually change
their their name of the town or the city
um through this
[Music]
legislation well I
um I
you have just thank you representative
you have two parts to your um question
I'm just kind of going back into the
um I have for the the town the
legislative
body so that's the town meeting
right and then for the municipality I've
got the governing
body because they don't have town
meeting it would be the select board um
and of course those process both have to
have you know fully public notice public
hearing and so forth um in terms of
renaming municipality I I don't have it
right in front of me but I think that
that would require I'm I'm quite sure
that require uh the a legislative act
the mountains rivers and I'm quite sure
the the name of municipalities would
require a legislative act and this this
bill does not um cover that you'll not
the language of the bill says geog
graphic features and
sites and uh that's different from a
representa you're muted unmute yourself
please thank you good morning um we have
a process now for this and I'm just
wondering why what we what what's the
Improvement that you seek to
gain well thank you for the excuse me
thank thank you for your question and um
the reason we need to have this is that
yes there's a process now somebody can
make a proposal to the United States
board if they
wish but such a proposal um would not
really be looked upon as having come
through a process in the state so it' be
highly unlikely
to be
accepted the real reason we need this
though is that we are dealing with you
know culturally
historical um issues that are of great
importance to Native
people and so the state because we don't
have a federally recognized
tribe um if we don't have a process like
this we can't
ensure that we have historically
accurate in a document
proposals um nor can we ensure that the
appropriate review by the commission and
nor can we ensure that um there that the
town you know the legislative process is
respected in the town or the
city um
and the uh so anyways I mean I think we
really need the bill I I I I I I don't
think it really is actually quite
possible to do this without the
bill follow up follow up
it um in terms of the uh historically
accurate and documented names uh I'm not
aware of any successful attempt to do
this um I know in my community there was
an effort a few years ago to try to
change the spelling of the coico
river uh and that did not succeed at the
federal level and I think in part
because that was not a proposal that had
consultation thank you representative
Shu thank you madam chair good morning
Senator um I'm curious um if there
apparently appears to be some
disagreement among um groups involved if
the commission
disagrees with name that's put forward
by one group would they have I don't
know if you'd call it veto
power I believe that the language in the
bill now essentially ensures
that because it puts that review
Authority in the commission not anywhere
else I also would say that I think that
the likelihood of any
successful of any naming propos Al going
forward and up the chain that does not
have their approval has just no
likelihood of
succeeding for for all the reasons that
we would we would we would think um and
as I said I I cannot speak for the
commission or for any other tribal
entities um what the bill does is the
the the language that was objectionable
to the commission I mean the the the
additions that the commission found
necessary um are now in the bill
completely in the bill so that's the
best I could
do Senator that's if we adopt your
Amendment correct yes thank you yeah
thanks for the correction M
chair okay represent
lro thank you madam chair what may I ask
what are the primary forms of
documentation you use to ensure
historical
accuracy I I know it must be a lot of
different sources depending on the
situation but would you say the couple
of few that
you well well thank thank you for your
question um you know I love historical
research that's I spent my career uh
doing and um you always have to evaluate
sources right I mean there are lots of
deed documents there are early
Maps um there are early uh treaty
instruments um um there is there are
Town histories there are many many
places in which names might appear and
so with any
historical um valuation of those you you
have to valuate um and I think that the
importance here particularly of the the
review of the uh commission Native
American Affairs and others is that um
spelling is really complicated uh you
know you've got you have English English
language speakers who were trying to
transliterate what they were hearing
from native people and um that's why the
you know contemporary uh abnis really
have the uh ability the best ability to
determine what was what the actual word
is and what an appropriate um spelling
would be it's a process it's a process
and and that's why it's important that
the commission of Native American
Affairs uh be involved because they're
they're going to be able they're going
to have the best um available resources
uh to re review um what is being brought
forward as a proposed um historically
accurate and documented abnaki name
thank
you thank you Senator I'd like to call
on representative Schmidt as one of the
other
sponsors thank you very much Madame
chair uh good morning colleagues um uh I
I as co-sponsor of the bill I don't have
the opportunity to ask questions today
so I've chosen to uh testify a little
bit
uh and I want to thank Senator waters
for his long-standing efforts uh to
advance the cause of the recognition and
the honoring of the indigenous peoples
uh of our area um I I'm late Comer to uh
this topic having uh had
only semiconscious awareness of names uh
around the area that clearly are not Ang
names um and the East Coast has a lot of
state names that are clearly referenced
uh know New York New Jersey and so forth
reference uh European Heritage some
names like Pennsylvania are constructed
names uh I come from the Midwest
originally where uh the names of states
are
overwhelmingly uh so-called Indian names
as an 80-year-old I've used the wrong
term all my life uh until learning of
course that
the name Indian is completely
inappropriate uh but the indigenous
people of this area the abanaki have
been here for something like 13,000
years uh and they're still here they
never went anywhere they were never
driven out like many um many of the
Southern Coastal tribes uh they've been
here all these all these thousands of
years and they're still here uh and and
and and I am fully in support of
promoting and and fostering greater
Consciousness on the part of our
citizens about uh the Heritage that we
have the rich rich Heritage that we have
uh wonderful names think of names like
pem jaset uh the marac itself uh is an
uh is an indigenous name uh nasua is an
indigenous name unlike names like Dover
Portsmouth and so forth and I think
there is no attempt whatsoever ever on
the part of any one reasonable and
certainly no significant effort to to to
abandon ex existing Town names uh but I
think it's important that uh that names
that have an indigenous background uh to
the degree that they are attested and
historic and authentic uh that to the
degree that they are uh not yet used um
that it would be advantageous uh I'll
just cite one example it's not a local
example but uh Lake
Superior uh I believe in the song of
fawaa and uh the The Wreck of the Edmund
Fitzgerald the name gugi is named uh and
that is the original name and I think
that our children should be educated to
learn the names uh of uh areas or towns
lakes rivers whatever um and to the
degree that uh that we uh discover uh
because I'm told that the original
settlers were very
industrious uh in recording uh at least
the best version they could come up with
but Senator water's already talked about
trying to transl trying to transliterate
a name which was not written down uh the
the abanaki were
pre-literate uh and did not have a
writing system so it was left to the
settlers to attempt to um you know to
record a name but they were very
industrious in doing so and we have you
know naragansett
and uh and kukuk uh and so forth names
of rivers uh and and look and and
mountains to some degree I'm not in
favor of
naming uh geographical features and so
forth that don't have
original uh indigenous names and
wouldn't be in favor of adding a name or
creating a name it has to be a
historical name uh but there are some
situations where U I've been told
something about the baker River uh that
is a that is a a source of of uh
unhappiness on the part of the
indigenous people that that name is
applied to the that River uh but
basically I think that Senator Waters
Bill uh which I'm proud to be a
co-sponsor is a very good first step but
it certainly has to be done within the
existing structure there's a federal
structure there's a state structure we
have the commission which is uh is
active and very involved we have to be
guided by uh by the council the
knowledge the experience of the
indigenous people who are still here as
I said and they're more of them we may
be aware of many many New Hampshire
natives have indigenous uh uh DNA in
their in their blood uh in their system
and and there is an existing uh
mechanism so uh it may be that there's
some aspects of the bill that need to be
improved or whatever uh so I don't like
the word renaming for example it we
would be to the degree that it's
appropriate uh uh
restoring uh an indigenous name to some
kind of a geographical feature uh that's
at and maybe uh uh there's a mountain
so-called a big hill called Blue job uh
north of Dover uh it may well have an
indigenous name and and that name should
be displayed and recorded blue job would
um would remain but but the S this our
children should be aware of the fact
when it is the case of an indigenous
name so uh I won't take any questions
because I have no expertise in this uh
but I'm I I have an awareness and I'm a
big supporter of the idea that we honor
and support and recognize the tremendous
contribution uh of the indigenous PE
people to the state of New Hampshire and
more than just names but names are an
important very important aspect of this
bill so with that I I'll end my
testimony and look forward to working
together with the committee and uh with
the indigenous people who are uh on the
who are in attendance today and will'll
will guide us in their testimony
upcoming so thank you very much Madam
chair thank you representative Schmidt I
foran thank you very much Madam chair
I'm Timothy Oregon from um Trafford
County district 6 the towns of Durham
and Madbury um and I just since I signed
on as responsibility I learned for
example that the Oyster River which run
through my community originally original
name was shank C and it apparently um it
apparently is the oy river is apparently
a translation of a chantastic means like
a river with many shellfish on it so
there's um and representative Schmidt
and especially Senator Waters have
covered a lot of the ground so I don't
need to go on too long but um this bill
does recognize that names are important
and this will um this will create a
process whereby um new names that new
names that are based in the abanaki
culture um will be historically accurate
ones so we don't want to on the one hand
we would like to have more abanaki names
to represent their um past and
continuing in future cont ution to our
community there are the stewards of the
land that we all cherish so much um but
also make sure that those are
appropriate and historically accurate
names um so like there's a so just to
make sure we're not just arbitrarily
making up making so on the one hand we
want to have the real historically
accurate abanaki names in place but we
also just don't want to make up fake
names this doesn't uh affect any uh
affect any existing names um although
there is controversy over the baker
river which actually my uncle had a farm
was on the baker River so I'm like
shamed to say I do nothing of the uh
history of it that's um also doesn't
affect uh Native uh Native American
inspired place names which either aren't
necessarily historically accurate like
Shakur um so certainly Mount Shakur the
village of Shakur Lake Shakur the river
Shakur can all continue to be called
that even though there's no evidence
that Shakur there's no hard evidence
that Shakur actually existed or even um
things named after uh you know Indian
Native Americans from tribes uh outside
the uh you know other than the abanaki
like Mount Duma which is uh the mountain
where the Waterfield Valley ski resort
is for example is named after a famous
Shaunie Shaunie remember the Shaunie
Nation so this is a this creates a so he
this creates a process which makes sure
we have you know appropriate and
historically accurate names and um so I
think it may need some more tweaking I I
I certainly um I I have a copy of
Senator water suggested amendments and
that's something I think we should go
for that would improve the bill and
um that's about all I have to that's I
all about say say about it um I'm
tempted to bring up the fact is separate
paragraphs for both um
municipalities for for both towns and
cities but I guess I'll leave that out
that that was a bill that we debated on
the floor last week which was didn't
even go through your committee so that
I'll leave that out of it so anyway I
think this is a it's a matter of some
controversy but um I I'm uh glad I
co-sponsored with co-spon and uh I hope
the even committee um doesn't move
forward the bill we have raised
awareness of of an important issue so if
you have to take any
questions thank you representative
forgan
seeing none I call Chief pce excuse me
represent I have one quick question were
you suggesting we should change the name
of the baker
River I uh I just said there's some
controversy over that Baker was a uh
well first of all he was from
Massachusetts um but um he was a he was
a leader of a band of uh you know a band
of white people who killed a large
number of native people back when we're
taking over New Hampshire so he's uh
he'll probably he's an historical figure
who in retrospect uh doesn't look quite
as worthy of having a geographical
feature named after him as as seemed the
case when the river was named um I uh I
mean I didn't know I didn't know why
it's named The Baker River until just a
few months ago myself and I've been uh
visiting that uh visiting visiting that
River for you know over 50 years so I I
didn't know it so that's local that's
something the people in grafting County
will have to debate amongst themselves
so
yeah um Madam chairman uh if we could uh
we'd like to allow Ken Gallagher from
you know Department of strategic
initiatives than he was the next person
but if you prefer to be after him and
then I would prefer that Kathleen Blake
representing the Native American
commission go after him and then we'll
follow if we could
Mr
Gallagher yes uh thank you madam chair
um so yes I'm Ken gallager I am a
principal planner at the office of
strategic initiatives and among my other
duties I am the designated contact for
New Hampshire with the federal board on
Geographic names so I just thought it
would be helpful if I describ to you the
current process uh that we use um for
proposing reviewing new Geographic names
in the state um we are basically a
reactive body at this point um I reive
notice from the board on Geographic
names for any proposals for new names in
the state and I review those proposals
with input from members of the Council
on resources and development um which
serves as the state's Geographic names
Authority at this
point um we do this review with cord
normally um via blind copy emails we
don't actually do it in our cord
meetings
um each member of court is given time to
review the naming Proposal with
colleagues in their departments and
that's usually about a six- week
period um I then review and summarize
the positions of the Departments and I
send the resulting information to the
BGN and um the board of geographic names
will also have directly solicited
responses from Municipal and County
governments and any other interested
parties um for any any of those
particular um names that are proposed um
as Senator Waters noted the um board on
Geographic names does not reach out to
Native American groups in New Hampshire
because there are no federally
recognized tribes in the state so I have
therefore on occasion consulted with
members of the commission on Native
American Affairs on certain naming
proposals and I am open to Consulting
with uh the commission on all naming
proposals going forward um just for a
little history since 2007 um when I
became the geographic names contact we
have only reviewed 24 naming proposals
so a little around two a year and um in
addition to that I've corresponded with
about the same number of members of the
public on Geographic names that did not
go forward to a proposal so that's
that's just the background on the
current uh state of how we do things
with the names and I'll be happy to take
any questions thank
you
representative
Shu thank you madam chair uh good
morning Mr Gallagher um I'm curious um
it seems that there would be
instances where for example differing
tribes would prefer different names for
the same
places um how would an instance like
that be
resolved well really the the the status
of our board is not to make a decision
at this point anyway um we're not we're
not sending proposals of Our Own in now
that that will change if this bill is
passed we could certainly do that and
other states do that but at the moment
we are simply One Voice among many um uh
sending our comments back to the board
on Geographic names so for instance if
there is disagreement and we're able to
identify that there's different groups
with different you know different um you
know perspectives we would send all that
information in to the federal board um
and there may we you know we may as a
group have have a particular sense of
what we want to do but we we do send in
all of the um dissenting information as
ourselves thank
you all
right seeing no further questions Miss
Blake
thank you madam chair good morning
everyone uh I am speaking to you from
dakina the traditional homeland of the
abanaki Penacook and wabanaki people's
past and present um Madam chair would
you like me to read the statement that
the commission has submitted or are you
all set on that thank you we have
received that and I at least have read
it so please just give
us
okay your highlights or any personal
testimony okay thank you ma'am uh I do
appreciate the amendment that was sent
uh late yesterday afternoon by Senator
Waters um at because I I have
requirements for hosting meetings with
the commission that require both
planning on their part all but two of us
are
employed uh and I must have a 24hour
meeting notice um sent out I could not
speak with my members of my commission
um because there was not time so the
statement that I submitted yesterday on
behalf of the commission remains Our
advice and um despite the the the um
amendment that has been submitted so I
couldn't meet with them um however I I
would like to make um a couple of
remarks as an individual and a resident
of New
Hampshire um I personally still have
serious concerns about this bill and I
went through the language carefully of
the Amendments and here are some
examples of things that concern me it
the phrase May recommend the naming or
raming is not the same language language
as to restore the actual traditional
abanaki word for that
location um the word review to me means
that I might read something look at it
um it does not say to me that I may have
input on upon it in any way or to render
an opinion review is doesn't say that to
me perhaps that's my lack of knowledge
about the law I don't know the words and
May when requested are concerning
because um if there is no request from
during that process then there's no
input um The Words the town shall inform
the commission just means to me what it
says they'll tell us that does not say
to me and you have um the ability to do
anything with that um
knowledge I also am concerned about the
13 tribes bands and organizations that
are listed on the contact list and
giving all of them all of us an
opportunity to have input um whether
each band chooses to have input or not
is irrelevant they should still be given
the opportunity no one band has any more
right to say um their opinion than any
other so I think it's really important
that all of the local peoples have the
ability to um make statements and and
have input the original names of the
places in New Hampshire um that were
used and shared by the first people of
this land are important to to all of us
they are still used in many locations as
people have pointed out despite the fact
much of the history of the people who
have called this place home for many
millennia has been falsely created to
represent the narratives that the
writers wished to project in legislative
hearings and I see many of you um the
same the same people that I've seen and
met before I I've heard some of these
um these erroneous Concepts listed as
fact you know indigenous people never
lived here for
example so we can do better and and we
really must do better my personal
objection to this bill is not about the
concept of it per se the restoration of
many original indigenous names is not as
difficult as it might sound many Town
histories include the original place
names of their communities there have
been books written that detail um what
the original names were so that there is
a lot that is known and what is not
known in my opinion should not be
created that merely adds more false
history into the mix and we have been
working very hard to to bring to light
the actual real history of this place
and don't need any more challenges um
for
that the so the creation of names even
if they are in the abanaki
language makes a problem in that
regard uh it continues to muddy the
Waters of the sad history of our First
Citizens and the truth needs to be told
it's very important truth
matters I I will answer any questions
you might have for
me thank
you on Bailey thank you madam
chair winess could you tell me when it
was said that indigenous people never
lived here I'd like to listen to that it
was said in two um hearings on two
different years in with this committee
um I don't have the exact dates in front
of me but many of you were sitting there
and heard that
stated by two different
politicians not this current
year I'm sorry this current year or
anyone present in this
room it was not stated by anyone that I
see present in this room no um and it
was not this year no however there are
individuals sitting here listening who
did hear those
welcome thank you very much I think
there see any other questions thank you
right you buing
up good morning uh committee members uh
we are uh I'm pleased to uh be with you
this morning to discuss some of these
issues I am the uh principal speaker or
the sore of the carak ban of the Pento
ABI people we're headquarted here in
alter New Hampshire I'm with my wife
Denise fulio I'm the head female speaker
of the kak band of the Penacook abnaki
people there's a lot of confusion about
um tribal identities and tribal status
within States in 1994 our tribe uh filed
a petition with the Bureau of Indian
Affairs uh uh and it was put in the
Federal Register on April 6th 1995
volume 6 number page 66 uh number 66
page
17614 the Bia has assigned us the number
151 our petition is still pending and
it's operational all tribes of petition
are protected under USC title 25 which
is Indian law whether you are federally
recognized state recognized unrecognized
or never even
petitioned hence because of our petition
filing we're considered Consultants on
all matters whether we're federal or not
federal regulations cfrs usually only
apply to Federal tribes and not state or
other categories of tribes over half of
the tribal communities in our country
are unrecognized only 574 actually are
and there's at least 600 that fit in the
other categories so keeping to use these
phrases there's no tribe here we are on
record with the Secretary of State in
New Hampshire and the attorney general
and the Bia knows where headquarters is
so let's just put the rest that there's
no tribe or no indigenous people living
here what um we've heard today is quite
interesting because we've been working
with strategic initiatives and the US
Geological Survey you know the mapping
people for decades since the 90s and
these issues come up all the time about
geographical place names many of them uh
go back to the Algonquin language
especially in New England abnaki was a
prevalent language and a language is a
root word language so every place name
you see there's a root word in there
that actually physically describes
location or what was done there I can
give you many many examples of how this
works but there are constructs that say
it's a a river feature or a mountain
feature or an occupation feature or a
feature where we did something in
particular so when we look at place
names like garik which got shortened it
actually was Maman which meant a place
where we spear fish salmon just like uh
Manchester is now show signs of amisk it
was neisig meaning a place where we fish
for fish we have no intentions of saying
Manchester has to roll back to that old
name but there are already high highway
signs that identify that old pass so
we're quite content with that we've been
working with Ken gallaga uh since he's
been in that office and we've pushed
back on on on inappropriate
inappropriate things like there was an
effort in holderness to name part of uh
sarm Lake pahas squ squar Cove to call
it Pocahontas Cove well Holiness didn't
want that tribal people didn't want it
we brought that to the commission and
they voted not to accept it so Ken and
us and all these agencies all worked in
Partnership already um all we can see
that this bill would codify what he
actually does dayto day and like Ken
said I I've dealt with this issue for
over 20 years I and just like him I say
it's a very small number of communities
that want to change things I give you a
case in point Warren New Hampshire got
into this controversy about Baker River
and Indigenous groups really want to
change that well Warren on its Municipal
level already voted not to change it so
that's dead it doesn't get to can at
this point because you don't have the
municipal support so that's being said
it's fine uh we are constantly being
asked to change the names of the
president range we know this is a major
issue with the US Geological Survey so
this process to change Mountain names or
to name unnamed features in the White
Mountains the presidential range is a
bigger and bigger thing and quite
frankly the abnaki do not have names for
many of these features let me just tell
you what we do have we've been we have
the most extensive library of State town
and Indigenous history in our own tribal
headquarters
we have records back to the
1700s several of your towns already have
these narratives of what the place names
were called we've taken all these
resources and we have with the Fiscal
Agent for incc which stands for uh
indigenous New Hampshire Collective
collaborative we started this with a lot
of alumni and uh exh professors at UNH
and historians and other interested
parties archaeologists anthropologists
and others we have an public domain
right now an OJs map it's an interactive
map we already have all the trails ABI
Trails already digitized on this map and
what did we find they all follow our
highways and our riverways and they also
lead to each one of the villages where
we had a place so this this data is
already in there not to mention the fact
the department of historical resources
already did the same thing we
independently because of copyright
issues we independently recreated these
trail map app s they were originally
identified in 1950 by a guy named
Chester price who was one of the leading
uh New Hampshire archaeologists who did
a lot of research back in the day we
validated and vetted almost all of his
work and right now we're looking at
records back to the 1700s from numerous
records including other tribal records
oral traditions and we have a layer
that's called um a sites Village sites
place name features and what we found
with this is uh we're going to roll this
out very soon any town could just go in
there and look what happened in your
location the only problem we're dealing
with right now there's so much data in
this map we have to figure out how it
can be actually used uh you know in
research with people it it's it's
daunting because there are so many
features in the state that are named by
us so why did we've we've we've gone in
a position to it elist and the reason is
as Kathleen has said we find amb
ambiguous language like and May and when
requested and as necessary there's
several of those and May and may what it
does when you start putting ambiguous
alternatives on how you look at this it
it blows up the whole system we expected
this to be an all- inclusionary Bill
where all participants whether it's the
DHR uh the Strategic initiatives the
municipalities uh we figured all the
tribes of consult
that are already like I said protected
under us title 25 that's why the state
has so many people on that list these
are all entities that are protected
under a self-determination Clause of the
of the federal government so we said you
know this would be great if this was
just a a codification of procedure but
when you start throwing in Ma and ws and
then if necessary and if requested these
all have to be removed uh so we say it
it we already have a process uh we
didn't ask for this
um we can all work together and draft a
new bill for next session that will be
inclusive with the input of everyone who
actually works within this process and
come up with a pro you know a bill that
would work better for everybody involved
the only thing I heard from Ken is that
there are some areas where he doesn't
have the authority but I think this
could be codified if that's what you
really want to do and I think it' be
word Smith so that it's very clear what
the procedure looks like uh I think this
is more of a procedural thing and I
don't know if it's a legislative issue
bluntly I don't think it's legislation I
think it's a procedural thing that could
easily be documented elsewhere but
that's why I say I I'd prefer to see
this itl I think it opens up what we
call an exclusionary process a town
could create a Disneyland feature we
already had this happen once in the
state eloa is not a true traditional AB
necki name that was a state contest to
name the beach and that that should have
never happened we just don't want that
to happen again we don't want to see
where somebody uh comes up with a great
scheme and changes something uh we also
know there's a lot of romanticized place
names that were created uh in that W uh
the thorough time period you know the
Romanticism of of you know poetry some
of those uh We've we've had to accept
because they're so deeply ingrained in
our culture like Shakura did Shakura
actually occur but you know what we're
not pushing back on that that's that's
another narrative another time so we
just say if this was was meant to be a
codification of a process it needs to be
very carefully word smithed with no maze
or requested or as necessary or you know
these just make it ambiguous so with
that being said I'm willing to take any
questions anybody
has thank you representative
Shu thank you madam chair good morning
uh I guess it's Mr and Mrs pulia um I um
first I would like to assure you that I
don't believe anyone currently serving
on this
committee denies the existence of Native
Americans in the state of New Hampshire
uh I think my committee members would
back me up that um we do have a method
of retaining a bill for future work and
I was wondering if you felt this piece
of legislation would be worth using that
process that you could perhaps work with
the sponsors on what would better
satisfy your
needs I I agree we've actually taken
each one of the re well we started with
the original and then there was a a
revision of that Amendment and another
amendment another amendment we've
actually uh looked at each one of them
it's minimal uh work has to be done is
striking out a May here or an or there
and and make it very clear that there's
a consultation process that's all we we
say needs to be done because as it's
written the consultation process seems
to be a little misleading at each step
so when you talk to municipalities it's
very clear that they have their own
self-governance issues and they can they
can make their recommendations they can
have votes depending on you know they
could have Town meetings they could put
ballots and petitions there's a whole
process for them to to put that on you
know in their form but when it comes to
Ken Gallagher and and the DHHR and the
commission I think it should be all
integrated as a Consulting party group
right and all tribes should be consulted
no um One Tribe should not be picked
just because they happen to be singing
the song the town is looking for um all
tribes should be consulted and if a
project is truly righteous then there
shouldn't be an
argument we we've actually I'll give you
another case and point a couple of towns
have actually had mascot issues and this
is kind of off the track but and they
they canell with a tribe outside the
region to get approval on a on an an you
know an offensive name uh that's
inappropriate you you go to your local
community and find out if it offends us
I don't care if it doesn't offend
somebody in the west coast that's a
tribe so we we want this to kind of keep
it local we think this is granite state
issues and we want to keep it within the
granite state if we can so that being
said we do see outside influences which
sometimes can screw up things and uh
like Pocahontas had nothing to do with
New Hampshire how did that get
interjected into our narrative uh
Pocahontas is from you know the Virginia
so that's the kind of thing we try to
push back out and oh by the way there
are Pocahontas renamings all over the
country Ken Galla could could tell you
there we just was shocked how many
people have changed places to Pocahontas
just because they felt warm and fuzzy
about it any more
questions uh not from the committee
thank you oh excuse me represent site Mr
F does anyone speak abanaki to today is
it SP is there a language spoken uh well
it's an interesting thing we we still
I'll be blunt we we speak like little
children because all of our um language
has been well documented back to the
1700s unfortunately um it's not like
this we don't have first language people
that can actually like converse with one
another in a living language actually
needs children you need like the Youth
of your community to speak it and
unfortunately we're now all adults
and and what we do is we speak it and we
can write documents in it but it's it's
more of a labor of love it's like it's
like trying to write in Latin today you
know it's like if you had to write
something in Latin You' you'd be you'd
be scratching your head trying to put
the sentence together but we can still
do it right with determination and love
comes success yeah and and abnaki is
much like Latin in the Algonquin
language I'm going to give you a lesson
here all the root words of all the other
alanan speaking uh uh groups all the way
from Main to to the West Coast are all
derived from abnaki root words we're
like the Latin of the Algonquin language
all the ancient words embedded in our
language so we know the word for Kansas
means the place of the Willows we know
the Mississippi what that word means
because that was another Algonquin word
uh Michigan there's a long list a long
list of these names actually are derived
from abnaki language narratives
representative scitec teaches uh Latin
when he is not the clerking for this
committee so he understands it very well
yeah that's funny uh I
don't see any other questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
Simmons she's raised her hand she wishes
actually before Miss Simmons Sher G had
now miss gold you can unmute yourself hi
there uh thank you madam chairman and
members I submitted written testimony
I'm not going to go into detail about
that um unless you know people are free
to ask me questions my name um
well s IND
nasum uh nood Dad I said hello I'm Sher
Gould I live in Warner New Hampshire and
um I'm a basket maker a professional
basket maker uh I'm speaking I come to
testify on behalf of the nagan abanaki
tribe we're one of many many bands and
tribes as Paul pulio has uh indicated we
were active together in starting the
commission on Native Affairs 10 years
ago 11 years ago and getting it through
the legislature it was set up to serve
all of the native people in New
Hampshire
including um including tribal members
since the commission was formed we've
had some State recognition
that's happened for abanaki tribes by
the state of Vermont and um here we are
we're all here together and the
commission is set up to serve all of us
and we're just anxious to work
with the process and um and help the
towns I'll take any questions if anybody
has
any right I don't see any thank you very
much for your T yes are you are you
speaking in support or in opposition I
haven't read your
testimony I'm in support of the
you
hey there's anyone else who wishes to
test a please raise your hand and
you all right seeing none I will close
the hearing on Senate Bill
and um I I just wanted to let
representative zitec know I'm here thank
you he's noticed that you and
representative Judy are both here thank
you thank you all right I'm a co-sponsor
of senville 57
[Music]
so okay at this time I'm going to open
the public hearing on SP 57 and call
Senator
Carson good morning Madam chair um for
the record my name is uh Sharon Carson
I'm have the pleasure of representing
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of londonairy Hudson and Auburn and I
have today for your consideration Senate
Bill
57 which uh allows pharmacy technicians
and interns to remotely perform
non-dispensing
tasks um this legislation would codify
emergency order number 13 which went
into effect uh in March of last year I
was approached to introduce this
legislation by pillpack which is a new
hampshire-based
Pharmacy that had sought to make this
remote practice permanent through a
waiver to the Board of Pharmacy however
the board responded that they did not
have clear statutory authority to do so
and recommended that pillpack uh contact
the state legislator to introduce this
legislation you will hear testimony
about how the work from home program has
shown positive Trends in employment
employees satisfaction and productivity
and very importantly uh patient safety
passing this legislation will help to
ensure that these opportunities can
continue after the state of emergency
ends codifying this emergency order now
will also allow the Board of Pharmacy
ample time to create rules needed to
address technical details without
disrupting the workflow of pharmacies
utilizing remote pharmacy technicians
bottom line is that it is good for
consumers good for employees and good
for business I know stakeholders are
working um and and they have uh we have
adopted a clarification Amendment and so
um I would ask you for your
consideration and ask for the passage of
Senate Bill 57 thank you very much um
Madam
chair thank you Senator um anyone have
questions Senator Carson represent s
uh Senator Carson would you mind
spelling or saying the name of the
agency or Pharmacy that wanted
this Sil pack or something P yes pill
pack p i l l p a CK sorry I of course
I'm sorry no that's okay it's you know
this um form of communication can
sometimes be a little dodgy so it's
okay thank you thank you very much Mr
chair um I I there are other folks who
testify who will be able to answer I
think questions um a lot better than I
can who have knowledge of the industry
so I would like to thank you all for
your time this morning it's good to see
all of you and it's good to see you
survived the uh the uh procedure that
you had to go through last week of three
days of uh session
so yeah it was definitely felt like a
procedure yes thank you all very much
and have a great afternoon thank you
Senator oh I'll be seeing you at 1:30 so
we'll talk to you then bye bye thank
you okay um going to call Chris rosan
you unmute
please thank you Mr Vice chair uh Madame
chair Mr Vice chair and members of the
committee my name is Chris Roshan and I
represent pillpack
pillpack is a fullservice pharmacy that
offers patients a safe and Innovative
way to obtain prescriptions using
convenient packaging modern technology
and personalized service in fact
pillpack was founded right here in New
Hampshire by a second generation
pharmacist and today pillpack is
licensed Nationwide and is an
independently operated subsidiary of
Amazon our Manchester New Hampshire
facility employs more than 500 full-time
New Hampshire workers and processes more
than 100,000 prescriptions each month
for patients across the country we are
here today to provide support for Senate
Bill 57 this bill would allow pharmacy
technicians and interns to continue to
perform non-dispensing tasks such as
data entry and prescription transfers
remotely after the covid-19 state of
emergency ends we would like to thank
the stakeholders who worked with us to
improve this bill including the New
Hampshire pharmacist Association and
representative Merchant the bill bill
before you today includes the Senate
Amendment crafted to address stakeholder
concerns and ensuring that all quality
and patient safety standards continue to
be met making the language fit better
into existing statute the amendment also
changes the effective date to upon
passage to ensure these practices can
continue without interruption when the
state of emergency ends we would also
like to thank governor sonunu and the
Board of Pharmacy for their leadership
on this issue last March when they
approved this practice during an
emergency meeting and through emergency
order number 13 these emergency actions
allowed pillpack to continue to process
and deliver critical medications to
patients in their homes while maximizing
the number of pillpack employees who
could work safely from their own homes
now let me be clear pharmacy technicians
and interns are and should be supervised
by licensed pharmacists technology makes
remote supervision not only possible but
also safe and effective this is why even
PRI prior to the covid-19 pandemic 11
states had allowed pharmacy technicians
to perform certain tasks from home under
remote pharmacist supervision this
practice has expanded significantly
during the pandemic with 34 States
including New Hampshire currently
allowing some form of remote work for
pharmacy
technicians as far as we are aware the
expansion of remote supervision has been
safely implemented across the country as
well as right here in New Hampshire the
National Association of boards of
pharmacist and ABP developed remote work
model language for pharmacy technicians
which this Senate bill Senate Bill 57
reflects since implementing the remote
work program we have seen positive
Trends in employee job satisfaction
productivity and prescription accuracy
all technicians and interns continue to
be supervised by licensed Pharmacists
and have access to their supervisors by
email phone and secure instant message
Chat including video screen share for
support and guidance as needed
consistent with pillpack's existing
operations we have seen a sustained
increase in job satisfaction and our
quality data has remained very strong
throughout the remote work period we're
continuously monitoring these important
metrics to ensure that we are meeting or
exceeding our strict patient safety
standards our remote work program has
also allowed pillpack to hire additional
technicians from different parts of the
state many of whom are specifically
seeking remote work pillpack is
continuing to grow and we plant to
increase our Workforce in New Hampshire
Senate Bill 57 will provide us and other
pharmacies the certainty that our remote
work program can continue after the
state of emergency concludes this will
allow us to continue to grow and higher
in New Hampshire where we process and
fulfill orders for customers across the
country we previously sought a waiver
from the New Hampshire Board of Pharmacy
to make remote work permanent that
request was denied by the board not on
substance but because the board did not
believe it had sufficient clear
statutory authority to Grant such a
waiver in its denial the board
recommended that pillpack and other
interested parties pursue legislation
that would provide the necessary
statutory Authority as a result we are
testifying before you today to ask for
your support to allow pharmacy
technicians and interns to continue to
perform non-dispensing tasks remotely
codifying this practice would create
much needed business certainty for
pharmacies in this state and for our
patients across the country
thank you again for considering this
important piece of Legislation during
these unprecedented times and I urge you
to vote Senate Bill 57 ought to
pass thank you uh representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr roson for testifying for us this
morning uh I have seen uh packaging
operations such as I believe you've been
describing uh and they're pretty
astonishing in terms of the
sophistication
of the uh the technology and of the
people involved so I'm just my question
is whether there was any opposition to
Senate thank you for your question
representative Schmidt uh the the bill
was passed unan unanimously in the
Senate and I am unaware of any
opposition at this
point thank you that's what I
suspected any other questions
Ron representative saite did I uh Mr
Rashon did I hear something about an
amendment involved in I looked at sb57 I
didn't see one Amed by the it has been
amended by the
sorry representative
fellow um thank you Mr chair I from Mr
ran I have a question um in the
bill let's see
it's on line 11 if you have a copy like
uh 10 and 11 it's the non-dispensing
activities and one of those activities
is product verification
tasks
which my limited knowledge of this um
makes me suspect that that's looking at
the the the pill or whatever it is to
make sure that it's it's um
characteristics
match what what it should be for
whatever kind of pill it is and how do
they do that
remotely thank you for your question
representative fellows uh product
verification can be done remotely via
high-tech Imaging of the container and
its contents so those images are
actually produced by the pharmacy
automation equipment and with this
automation there's also multiple barcode
scans Upstream to reduce defect effects
and ensure the product is selected
correctly the images of the dispense
medication the container and the label
are then compared to the reference image
by the pharmacist to verify the
correctness similar to what would be
happening in person but they're looking
you any other questions from the
committee for Mr
[Music]
Oran representative
sh thank you Mr chair um Mr my my
question is involving basically line 10
uh which says non-dispensing activities
include but are not limited
to uh so that means that you or some
other group would be looking for some
tasks other than those that are spelled
thank you for your question
representative Shu the purpose of this
bill is to uh codify the potential for
those remote non-dispensing tasks and
the Board of Pharmacy once they have
clear statutory Authority can also go
through normal rulemaking processes to
further Define those technical
components and build out guards that
they see fit uh in order for them to do
that they requested that they have this
clear statutory authority to begin with
all right so this basically would just
allow um for them to put forward in
administrative rules further
techniques that is correct as they see
fit thank you someone who serves on jel
car I appreciate
that representative
fellows thank you um I have another
question how how do you know if the in
in this kind of remote operation how do
you know the person who's doing the work
is actually the person who's hired and
qualified to do the
work thank you for your follow-up
question representative fellows so we
have a um well documented policy for
remote work which was attached to our
original waiver request of the Board of
Pharmacy includes a number of safeguards
in place to ensure that employees
logging into our system to perform work
are their credentials are verified and
validated additionally we actually have
a team dedicated to uh following up on
work from homework and closely
monitoring that quality as well as
through two-way video uh video
conferencing seeing the person who's
necessary any further question what do
followup well yeah thanks I just
wondered you you're saying when
necessary I'm just wondering how often
do you actually see an image of who's
actually doing the
work so today for our technicians who
are performing data entry tasks remotely
as part of their regular meetings with
their supervisors which occur weekly
those would be two-way video meetings
where you would see the person doing the
work additionally we have a member of
our staff who is dedicated to work from
home in inspections and doing those
periodically and randomly to make sure
that we're holding our team accountable
to high quality and holding our team
accountable to ensure that it's the
person uh doing that work thank you
represent
sh thank you Mr chair um another thought
occurs to me in the interests of uh
protecting patient um information what
kind of safe guards do you use to ensure
that uh these remote
hackable thank you for your followup
question representative Shu uh as part
of that work from home policy that I
referenced previously there are a number
of technological safeguards that are
included we provide the equipment for
our uh employees who are performing
remote non-dispensing tasks that
equipment includes the necessary encryp
as defined by Hippa and other related
rules to ensure that data security and
particularly protected health
information or Phi is kept uh secure
additionally um we require that our
employees are actually hardwired into
internet as part of that policy as
opposed to being connected through Wi-Fi
further contributing to the security of
those
CH I'm sorry apologies how long has this
place this executive order has been in
place since March of
2020 follow up
yes have there been any issues as a
order as far as we involving this
involving this procedure as far as we
are aware there have not been any issues
from our perspective at pillpack in
Manchester we have seen um similar or
improved quality and prescription
accuracy as well as improved job
satisfaction as
well no issues that we're aware of thank
you I have a question myself uh of the
employees since this is is all remote
how many do you have employees that are
not working in the Hampshire or are they
employees thank you for your question Mr
Vice chair we do have some non- New
Hampshire based remote
employees could you give me a ratio
roughly unfortunately I don't have that
that statistic immediately available
it's something that I can take as a
followup if you would like it I
Schmid thank you Mr Vice chair uh so Mr
roson uh your testimony seems to
indicate that this is kind of an
Innovative process that started here in
New Hampshire but I'm wondering and it
is spreading Nationwide through your
company's expansion but I'm wondering
whether any other states have it this
point codified as you are asking us to
do thank you for your question
representative
uh even prior to the covid-19 pandemic
there were 11 states that previously had
allowed Pharmacy Technics to perform
these tasks that we're asking for uh
during the pandemic that's increased the
34 States including New Hampshire with
many states considering codification um
but outside of those original 11 I'm not
aware of what other states have
successfully codified
today follow up Mr chair uh and and are
that is information that I actually do
not have immediately in front of me I
don't have the list of states but um if
interested I can certainly take that as
a
followup I think that would be
appreciated by the
again I understand that the pharmacy
board is going to be responsible to
ensure that staff has the Required
licensing and training how will um the
pharmacy board inspect uh local home
home
locations thank you for your follow-up
question representative um I can't
speculate on what the New Hampshire
Board of Pharmacy would do to to do
those inspections as I'm not a board
representative so I unfortunately I
don't have a comment on that at this
time thank you perhaps someone in will
be able to answer
call I I have one more question myself
regarding um what I asked you already
how would this affect this Bill affect
if you have employees working outside of
New Hampshire doing this how would this
Bill affect their um their ability if
statue thank you Mr Vice chair um that
would be something that would be
considered on a state-by-state basis so
we would have to look at the the rules
or statutes in the Resident state where
they're living as well as ours um as New
Hampshire licensed technicians
regardless of where they're living they
are licensed by the New Hampshire Board
of Pharmacy and therefore subject to New
Hampshire rules uh as as enforced by the
board so we'd be obligated to uh still
follow those New Hampshire rules and
cons it on a state byst state basis
depending on what state they might be
living
in okay thank you I still would like
that information that I asked for if you
could get it to me later um any other
questions for Mr
ran seeing none thank you for your
testimony Mr ran anyone else wishing to
testify on this bill I only had two
hand there being none I'm going to go
ahead and close the public
chair before we go on to the next bill
I've just been informed that the Senate
has requested that the house not hold
hearings on
Thursday so is there a strong preference
among members of the committee for
Tuesday or Wednesday of next week since
they don't want us to do it on Thursday
me Tuesday is not okay Tuesday is also
not the best for me either Wednesday's
good all right Wednesday would be better
for
me so we've got two no Wednesdays three
no
Tuesdays
um
and Miss Simmons is wants to speak to us
uh promoted promoted her
okay Madam chair I would just point out
to the clerk that obviously
representative fellows has joined us and
I see representative Judy on out thank
you did that before this
hearing all
right Madam chair
yes uh are you confirming that we're
going with scheduling on the
21st I'm trying to have that decided yes
okay just let just uh verbally let me
know thank
you any other people members of the
committee wish to make an
opinion um Madam chair uh Wednesday's
worked fine for me as well okay are you
are you going to intend on exacting
anything that
day
probably actually no that we've got that
13p part licensing bill I don't think
we'll have time to exec
anything yeah if uh if you're not going
to exec anything that day then that
that'll be fine I'll I'll be
uh I'll be in and out you'll be
working okay uh in that case we'll try
Wednesday Miriam if you could move it to
Wednesday that appears to be uh
no more objectionable than any other day
thank you this can be uh posted in the
calendar in sufficient time too it's
well that's why I'm asking now because
the calendar is closing right right now
okay pretty much right now yes it will
be in the
case that bit of housekeeping taken over
I will open the hearing on Senate Bill
Whitley I believe
REM she okay repres with the excuse me
Senator Whitley you can just unmute
us
okay there we
go uh good morning members of the
committee and chair uh for the record my
name is Becky Whitley and I'm honored to
serve New Hampshire Senate District 15
which includes the wonderful communities
of conquered Penacook hener hopkington
and Warner so I'm here this morning to
introduce Senate Bill
114 this bill is a public safety bill
that ensures everyone who uses and
enjoys New Hampshire's public cultural
and natural resources can do so without
fear or threat of discrimination or
violence we all know that our beautiful
public places are a huge reason why so
many people come to New Hampshire to
live work and play safe beautiful open
space is the legacy of the Granite State
and ensuring that everyone feels safe in
these spaces is critical to creating a
welcoming and robust recreational
economy in the granite state now you'll
note that the original version of this
bill as introduced simply required that
the state agencies who Patrol public
areas uh required them to establish a
protocol for addressing incidents of
racial discrimination and bigotry uh
record and then log those incidents it
also in section five codified the
training portion of Governor sununu's
executive order creating the um
executive order that created the
commission on law enforcement
accountability a community and
transparency commission so um what
remains in the bill um is what you have
before you uh the remaining section is
Section Five and this is a compromis
position that ended up passing the
Senate unanimously and a 24 to zero vote
so this version retains only the
language that was worked on with the
bill sponsors with Chief skippa of the
New Hampshire police standards and
training Council regarding the training
that that all law enforcement in New
Hampshire should undergo we worked
closely with Chief skippa toensure sure
that the language was consistent with
their already in motion plans to provide
this training and that the language was
consistent with a key recommendation of
the leak commission and the governor's
order establishing the commission it is
worth noting that over the course of 10
weeks this summer The Lea commission met
26 times uh and after all this work and
public input the leak commission
established by the governor's executive
order issued a report full of
legislative recommendations that were
agreed on by all members of the
commission now this is no small feat uh
there were diverse uh stakeholders at
the table and I really do commend each
and every member of the leat commission
for devoting their time and energy to
this difficult but important work so
again what remains in this bill is a
compromise position that's coming over
from the
Senate establishing this training for
all lawn enforcement um and it's fully
in line with the leak commission and the
governor's executive order so there are
folks behind me that will testify but
I'm happy to take any
questions thank you
questions uh Madame chair representative
O'Brien if I may please thank you uh
Madam chair thank you uh senator for uh
taking my question uh I I get to jist
and I agree with this uh it seems uh
particularly now timely uh but however
which course are the police going to
take uh is this going to be like a state
requirement course so what is taught in
nashar is taught in cobbrook and or what
happens if a community such as Nash
because Nash is a great City we're ahead
of the game on a lot of things if I
could brag about my hometown but what
happens if they have a curent program
that may not match exactly the state so
where does that lie on this subject
thank you for the question
representative and I agree Nashville is
a great Community you have a wonderful
police chief so that's why we were you
know the very essence of your question
that you know the differences in
communities is why we worked really
closely with Chief skippa so he runs
Chief skippa runs the New Hampshire
police standards and training Council
people call it the police academy so all
law enforcement um look to the police
academy to train their officers and to
um to help them with annual inservice
training so this won't add any
additional burden to local uh big or
small agencies but um they'll it'll just
uh enable the police academy to support
the agencies and providing this
training okay follow up if I may Madam
chair
follow up uh thank you madam chair uh
Senator uh I I think you might have hit
it but just for my clarification make
sure I heard correctly uh what I'm
saying would the state program be the
rule that every Community would have to
that's what I'm getting at in other
words the community could not come up
with their
own correct correct it right that's
correct it is the it is the police
academy the State Police Academy run by
Chief skippa that would provide this
training and then also support um the
local agencies you're correct okay thank
you senator for taking my question thank
you
madam
representative um thank you madam chair
I I think I figured it out
but
this I think I was confused by the
analysis that's on the bill that still
still ref refers to the Department of
Natural and cultural resources but this
actually has nothing to do with them as
anymore with the amendment correct thank
you for the question um and you correct
so this the what you have before you is
uh only section five of the bill is
introduced so the previous sections um
were removed by the Senate so what you
have before you is the compromise
commiss uh position from the Senate and
you're correct that um the analysis uh
is not applicable to what remains in the
Bill thank you for that clarifying
question thank you actually
representative fellows the department of
cultural resources has some employees
who are law
enforcement the Rangers or what you
might you might consider them and they
go through the police standards and
training and they they're affected in
that way that is correct yeah thank you
for that clarification that is correct
both the Department of Natural and
cultural resources and fishing game do
have law enforcement that do go through
the police academy that is correct thank
you so so
followup
please um so this applies to those uh
few employees that that are in those two
departments but it applies to all all
police all police officers correct and
so this
is were they not having any kind of um
training for these issues
before thank you for that thank you for
that question um so this actually um no
well I you know I can't speak to with
the training that they were having
before but this
codifies um a requirement for doing this
training this new training that it was
in the governor's executive order
creating the leak commission and then um
the police academy was already starting
the process to create this training so
this just codifies the governor's
executive order and the requirement to
do this training that was recommended by
the leak
commission okay thank you thank you
representative leus uh thank you madam
chair is uh anyone from the police
standards and training going to be
testifying if so I'll ask this question
of
them okay I've been informed no one's
here from there
so uh my question is
around what is the training going to be
around um especially implicit bias um
you know my concern is that there' be
nothing included uh that would have been
prohibited in the uh House Bill we heard
earlier House Bill 544 concerning
devices
Concepts you know sometimes called
whatever yeah I I'm sorry I can't answer
that question that would uh something
that would be directed to Chief skippa
um but the again the language that uh is
in the bill was in the governor's
executive order and in the in the
recommendations from the leak commission
thank you so I can't speak to the
specifics I apologize for
that representative C what Senator what
was the executive order number do you
know oh that's a good question I can
you
it was he had two different executive
orders the the first one was
202011 and the second one adding
additional uh parties I think to the
you thank you
other than the governor's executive
order have there been any instances
have shown requirement for this
Bill thank you for the question so we
did have an incident in conquer
conquer's within my district there was
an incident on some Trails um you know
some uh graffiti some really hateful uh
racially directed graffiti and also in
the in the hearing in the Senate we did
have a number of folks different folks
representing different communities of
color who uh testified to their own
experience um so you know we don't
collect this data in New Hampshire and
so a lot of the information was shared
by individuals who had experienced their
own um you know uh discrimination uh but
again this is not documented in we don't
collect this data in New
Hampshire follow up follow up so this
the these this these incidences though
are caused by New Hampshire citizens not
by our state or local employees
correct so uh well correct I mean the
one right so this is just to make sure
that our law enforcement are able to
respond to incidents in a way that makes
everyone feel safe so this isn't
targeting law enforcement this uh this
is helping them support the community to
make sure everyone feels
safe thank you thank
you
representative good morning and thank
you for taking my
question what do training have done to
prevent the graffiti that you're talking
about in the single
incidence so thank thank you for that
question um I can't I can't speak to how
it would have prevented it but certainly
it would support all law enforcement to
know what to do when this happens and to
respond in a way that makes everyone
feel safe um it's also really a public
message right that that New Hampshire is
a place that's welcoming for all right
so it's important you know as I said in
our my introduction of the bill you know
so many people come to New Hampshire to
play and live and work and we want to
make sure that we make everyone feel
safe right and so you know I was so uh
happy to work with Chief skippa who also
recognized the importance of community
policing building those relationships
with Community to make sure everyone
feels safe and you know there is this
really important economic side of our
Recreation right in New Hampshire so
many folks cross the border to you know
go to our beautiful uh Open Spaces our
mountains our recreational areas um and
so this is a public message uh that New
Hampshire is a place that welcomes
everyone
uh well you should remember
representative that that testimony might
have been to the towards the sections
that were deleted by the Senate
Amendment and not necessarily the
sections that's left please follow
that's
search actually representative Whitley I
have a question on that Senator Whitley
excuse
me it appears that after the amendment
the title is no longer correct because
what it's really dealing with is
training for our Law Enforcement
Officers would you agree with that I
would yep thank
questions seeing none thank you Senator
ofia thank you madam chair um really
happy to be here with the committee I
um I I you know for me this bill SB has
114 is a is I think from the Senate over
to the house side it's good comp it's a
compromise it's uh you know I think it
focuses on one of the main issues which
is making sure our law enforcement are
just uniformly trained on just some
implicit bias trainings I think it's um
it's nothing that you know it's
important for us to have uniform
training across um across departments
whether it's fishing game whether it's
uh or state troopers and making sure
everyone you know uh is following you
know somewh the same safety protocols
especially when making um others
primarily people of color like myself
feel safe in in the outdoors um and we
want to make sure that you know the
outdoors are a space where everyone
feels welcome um where everyone feels
like um where everyone can enjoy you
know the fresh air and um and and bask
in the Sun that we all get to so um I'm
really I'm really hopeful that everyone
will support this support this bill um I
think like I said it's a good compromise
to making sure that we all just get all
the trainings um uniformly across the
board so um with that I'll take any
questions as well by thank you
questions representative
schelz thank you for taking my question
and thank you madam chair um knowing the
issues around divisive Concepts do you
see this as being anything other than
equipping all of our um enforcement
officers in learning how to respond to
racist
incidents
or um isn't isn't that the main
purpose and did I hear that it was unan
unanimously supported in the Senate yeah
yes so this was you know following the
amendment it was unanimously supported
in the Senate and I think um I think
every you know with with whatever we all
do I think having the tools we need um
to address any situation across any
occupation is important so I just think
you know I think this is just another
tool for law enforcement to be able to
properly equip themselves and feel you
know feel like they can address it
because there's you know there's no such
thing as a one-size fits-all but I think
there's you know there are tools that
will help make sure that we can help as
many folks as we can
so other questions
pz thank you Madame shair for giving me
the opportunity to uh speak in support
of this bill uh my name is Maria Perez
I'm a state representative for district
23 in Milford um I believe this bill is
needed now more than anything we try uh
have a good relationship with our police
officers with anybody who works in the
law enforcement and for people like
myself people of color and people who
look different in all because of the
religion because of the culture will
look different this bill would um make
us feel more uh welcome and supported
and especially when we like me I enjoy
hiking I enjoy the parks I enjoy doing a
lot of working myself and
um this bill will make me more
comfortable knowing that if anything
like what I experienc last year walk in
my dog around my neighborhood one of the
TRS around my neighborhood and I was uh
harassed by someone and told me that um
I wasn't
welcome um they told me that I I was an
immigrant and I need to go back to my
country and my family doesn't belong in
a neighborhood
um and um when I called the police
department they didn't know how to
handle it um to be honest this kind of
Bill is needed uh we need to the police
department to be training to see how to
handle this kind of situation because I
I
feel a lot of people going through the
same things and um it's necessary for
all of us to feel
welcome um and I respect anyone no
matter what color you are no matter what
language you speak I feel so like part
of this community I feel like I've been
here 33 years and I've been working so
hard to learn the language to learn the
laws to to learn to be part of these
communities um so to be honest I I
believe that this bill will uh help us
to continue that relationship that we
try to build with the police departments
and uh make people feel more welcome and
make make
uh feel comfortable when it's time to
speak uh with the police officers thank
you so much for your
time thank
questions seeing none thank you very
much uh Katherine corer signed up to
speak but I don't see her on the
attendance
list Madam chair she I think might be
listed as Sierra Club
as what Sierra Club Sierra New Hampshire
Sierra Club oh okay we
will that makes it more difficult for us
to to to find
her her hand is up at least I assume
that's
her I was looking for for for the name
that she that was
listed if you
will promote her yeah I did see her very
hello um uh oh let's see sorry here I
am uh thank you and my apologies I um I
can't change the name of my
computer um but uh I uh thank you um to
the the chair and to the committee for
hearing my testimony today I submitted
some written testimony so I will just uh
quickly go over um the main points um my
name is Katherine corkery I uh am the
chapter director for New Hampshire
Sierra
Club uh and I represent 20,000 members
and supporters in the gr Granite State
and I appreciate all your time and
effort
in in the work that you do uh in this
committee and during those long sessions
um so thank you for that
um
we as you have gathered this bill has
been on a long journey um and it is very
different um than the way it
started um with an and as it was amended
by the Senate um um and I uh appreciate
uh the work that the Senate did um in
recognizing
the that the um state agencies that work
uh that have jurisdiction on our public
lands and public Trails um need to have
the the same
training um but what is and I appreciate
the work that the Senate did but we we
felt that this bill still was worthy of
our support um in addressing uh the
recommendations of the Lea commission um
and in my testimony I did provide the
link to the final report of the Lee act
um and uh if members of the committee
are interested in that uh it is
there and and um the the three main
points here are that um this bill did
pass 24 to zero in the Senate as amended
um that there were over a hundred people
who signed in support of the bill at the
Senate hearing and a petition um that
went um that addressed the original bill
which
included uh the Lea um training and um
to go to the uh Governor's executive
orders um and uh the senator was right
it was uh
20201 and
20203 um they it it it includes um it
expands the training at the police
training and standards Council to
include three new nonviolent training
sessions and um that those nonviolent
trainings those sessions um do include
deescalation uh ethics and uh implicit
bias and those are really important
tools for our law enforcement to have in
dealing with the public um these
are
uh and and it applies to law enforcement
in um game as well as uh the Department
of Natural and cultural
resources uh any all of the um the
policing agencies go through the police
academy and we we support the report uh
from the leak commission and and the
hard work um that they did in a short
amount of time and lastly the the
nonviolent training um as I said it is
critical to maintain peaceful and safe
community relations um there is a lot of
conversation about that in the leak
commission and um we do and lastly uh we
ask uh New Hampshire CER Club asked the
committee to pass S sp114 as as amended
and um I'm happy and available to assist
the committee in any uh further
discussions thank you are there any
kker seeing none thank you very
elone hello can you hear me yes thank
you yeah my name is as honei and I'm the
movement politics director for rights
and democracy New Hampshire I am
speaking in support of this bill I just
um want to start off by saying I am a
Muslim woman who wears hijab um and it's
vital that we're tracking verbal and
physical violence that happens in our
parks in our communities in our state in
general um and I share the story of a
Muslim woman who was walking with her
baby and was stopped by police officers
because people thought you know just her
presence U was a threat to them that's
just an example of implicit bias um I
also think it's quite sad and scary that
police officers are not trained in
deescalation and anti-bias training
already um police officers have power to
stop people and they walk around with
tools that kill and unfortunately
because of implicit bias and the way
we're portrayed particularly in the
media um we could be a Target um again
even unintentionally so I want to make
it clear I support this bill because it
does not have a fiscal note um I
staunchly oppose more funding towards
police agency I see this bill though as
harm reduction because I do believe we
need to use police Less in our
communities um but it is important that
any funding that being that's being used
for this is coming from the current
police budgets and that our police are
being trained to deescalate um in terms
of implicit bias training it is vital
that everyone understands that
stereotypes um can lead people to
criminalize people and there was a
representative who said if implicit bias
training is similar to HB 544 bill I
would say that HB 544 would would have
prohibited people from speaking about it
bias as systemic racism so essentially
teaching that we should not be treating
People based on the negative stereotypes
that we could be just internalizing
ourselves everyone should be able to
live safely and freely and enjoy the
outdoors white black and brown people so
please do support this
Bill thank
you will you take questions sure
representative
schz thank you madam chair um first of
all Ramadan Mubarak I hope I said that
correctly I'm learning um so as I
understand it you have a lot of
experience around these issues that the
leak commission has been discussing and
about implicit bias training have you
found that to be um well accepted in
conversations with law enforcement and
um something that they have embraced and
found to be mainstream
yeah thank you um representative I
really can't speak in terms of policing
um but I can just speak in general
people do want to have these
conversations because I don't think
people realize the ways we've
internalized say when we see certain
groups of people portrayed in the media
a certain way and then we could behave a
certain way in public or the fact that
you know racism is basically in in in
our systems and so in order to really
address them we need to talk about them
and so that they know like oh um if I
see a Muslim woman wearing hijab it
doesn't mean that she's a terrorist so I
should you know not approach in that
manner as well so I think uh it's well
accepted by everyone in the community
and definitely something that needs to
happen so we can get to a better place
you thank
you see any other questions is there
anyone else who wishes to testify
representative
oron representative
Horgan thank you very much Madam chair
so I'm represent Timothy Horgan I
represent the towns of uh dur and
Madbury um Durham is a uh somewhat more
diverse than the rest of New Hampshire U
because of the University of New
Hampshire which has more persons of
color than the stage as a whole and even
though we have a very well-trained
very fair police force there is um you
know there's racial tension even between
uh people the people of color who reside
in Durham and the police force and there
um haven't been
any major racially charged incidents in
Durham that I can remember but they have
H they do happen in New Hampshire and
then there's also I think there's a
level of mistrust even between the uh
White community and the police force
because for example large percent of the
homicides in Hampshire are officer
involved incidents um usually they're
rarely if ever convicted a crime in fact
most cases probably their actions were
justifiable but there is even even so
this even between the white community
and police force there's a level of
mistrust and certainly um we haven't had
anything like what's going on in uh in
Minnesota which is uh disgraceful but
Minnesota is also a peaceful white state
so like you know it happened
there could you could you speak as to
whether you're in favor or opposed to
the bill oh I'm sorry oh well I'm
imposed I'm very much in favor of the
bill and it's pretty simple common sense
and it just codifies what the police
academy should be and I think um is
trying to do already so like this is U
so certainly um you know the police
officers I don't think um police
officers you know they they should be
de-escalating incidents you know they
should not be killing civilians when
they don't have to you know they should
be treating everyone fairly regardless
of the color their skin or whatever the
other characteristics this is very very
common sense and um it's almost like a
it's almost uh pretty it's almost
unfortunate this bill is necessary but I
believe it is necessary and also um the
topic of HP 544 came up i' be represent
HP 544 anymore it is related in the
sense that um there is a possible
conflict between these two builds
although I think uh you know you should
pass this s to the Senate and HB 544 has
in fact not been passed by the by the
house anyway so that's it was table 347
184 anymore thank um do you have
anything else to say about Senate Bill
114 oh it's a it's it's an excellent
bill it's uh so common sensical it it's
so common sensible it shouldn't be NE
necessary but yes it is necessary and um
so I I I I think this should be passed
it's excellent thank you and whatever
else other member of the public that
do all right seeing none thank you very
much I'm going to close representative
fellows um I I don't want to testify I
just I'm disappointed that there's
nobody um to speak to us from police
standards and training is there some way
we can get them to come over here and
talk to us about this
bill not at this point representative
fellows however he's been certainly uh
Senator Whitley did testify who she
spoke to and you should certainly give
him give him a call and talk to him
about it if you like thank you that they
support my in my
experience oh thank you okay all right
seeing no other hands I'm G to close the
hearing on Senate Bill
1114 we are in recess until 1:30 Madam
chair yes representative sh thank you uh
if I may just
briefly uh I attended the Senate DNA
hearing yesterday and I can give the
committee a brief update on what
occurred with our bills there if the all
right well the this is entirely optional
for the committee we'll come back at
1:30 thank you um I'll just say house
bills 128 weather
modification uh 369 PT
modalities and 456 information from
Vital Records uh were all voted
recommended ought to pass uh unanimously
for the consent calendar House Bill 283
the Wentworth cheswell Bill uh was since
unfortunately we are already passed the
April 11th anniversary date for this
year they amended it to apply in years
going forward and that's recommended
unanimously ought to pass with amendment
to go on the consent calendar
House Bill
141 uh the bill exempting County
administrative officers uh they have
requested an FN with uh fiscal
information they are awaiting that and
House Bill 499 the facial recognition
Bill had a very long hearing the
committee had lots of questions on it
and they put off exing on that so that's
that's all I just wanted to let folks
know that we were pretty successful
yesterday very muchan did you say one of
the bills was amended in the
Senate 283 what were sches day
recommended oop pass uh the committee
adopted the amendment but none of these
have gone to the full Senate
yet did did the Senate Amendment change
anything title from our Amendment had um
put it for April 11th of this year which
like I said unfortunately has passed
they change that to next year and then
further down in the language of the bill
uh it just refers to uh endorsing
forward
fire Miss Marling if you put up our out
lunch
for
we mut yeah we muted uh I apologize to
you
all
set video on our video's on I can even
see US senator Carson yes good afternoon
again Madame chair good afternoon yes
thank you uh we had a little technical
difficulty here uh so Senate Bill
58 yes oh wait a second I got Senate
Bill 59 57 in front of me I just need to
switch folders here um let's see where
did I do with it oh goodness gracious
I've got don't ask me Senator no no I've
got multiple um uh folders in front of
me because I I had to leave um my
uh uh Judiciary so we're all
set
we're good to
go um would you like start Madam Madam
chair yes we started okay terrific good
afternoon um house Edna committee um and
Madam chair for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of londonairy
Hudson and Auburn and for your
consideration this afternoon I have
Senate Bill 58 with which uh is relative
the administration of the occupational
regulation by the office of professional
licensure and
certification um this bill makes changes
to the statutory Provisions governing
the regulatory boards and commissions
for technical profession and Health
Professions in order to conform to
oversight and administration by the
office of professional lenser and regul
regulation um this bill was a refile
from last session um the uh bill number
was Senate Bill uh
576 and this was a bill that was filed
by originally by Senator GAA and uh
unfortunately it was a bill that was
included in one of the Omnibus bills and
that Omnibus Bill was vetoed so in
speaking with Senator GAA this year we
both talked about um how important it
was that we refile this bill but what we
did was we divided into two separate
packages a policy package and a fiscal
package what you have in front of you
today is the F uh is the policy packet
and Senator GAA um is sponsoring the
fiscal package um we uh we took our time
with this bill in Senate Ed and day and
looked it over very very carefully
because as you can tell there are a
number of pages to this bill um and it
really makes some good changes but we
wanted to make sure that we were um we
were all on the same page on this the
only thing that we did do is we file I
filed an amendment we had received a
request from the vice chair of the
electricians board to include um
criminal background checks for um for
electricians that was adopted and I
believe um Miss Courtney is going to be
speaking to the need for another
Amendment we did adopt part of that
language which states that the board um
shall retain the authority to determine
the criteria necessary for licensing
applications um the other part of it um
really dealt with an issue that was
brought by uh representative Merchant as
you know representative Merchant used to
sit on the pharmacy board and the
amendment that uh Miss Courtney is going
to that's going to going to ask you to
bring forward is a comp uh some
compromise language that they both um
felt was appropriate so at this point
Madam chair I will um seize my testimony
and just say that um I know that um Miss
Courtney is here and she will be able to
walk you through this extensive bill and
I thank you all very much for your time
and your consideration this
afternoon thank you
Senator uh will you take questions
um I can try to but again it's it's
pretty extensive so um I will try to
answer a question representative Shu do
you wish to ask Senator Carson or
perhaps Miss Courtney yes this isn't
anything technical I don't think uh just
a clarification Senator uh you
mentioned uh approval um of applications
by the board was that referring
specifically to the electricians board
not all the boards no This was um
specific to the pharmacy board um at the
at that time we uh Miss Courtney and I
had had a discussion with M uh
representative Merchant this was some uh
language that we had all agreed on but
since then there have been subsequent
conversations and there she's bringing
forward more language um I do have um
the language but um I didn't think it
was appropriate that I present the
committee with an amendment so that's
okay I just wasn't sure who you were
exactly referring to okay terrific thank
you representative thank you in that
case I'll call on Senator GAA thank you
very much Madam
chair thank you madam chairman members
of the committee for the record Bob gas
Senator District 2 comprising 27 towns
in two congressional districts and Three
Counties um it's a pleasure to be before
you today uh to testify on Senate Bill
58 uh this is a bill that is really
needed uh as you may recall the office
of profess professional lure and
certification uh was established uh by
the legislature about six years ago
maybe seven now uh and it is it has uh
suffered uh from um uh changes in
leadership numerous changes of the
executive director uh has suffered from
covid uh and the the the uh Omnibus Bill
um problem uh and and it is in in great
need uh of being implemented uh I've
been through it as has director Courtney
uh and of course Senator Carson and the
committee uh this is a bill that
directly affects how our state boards
interact with the businesses the doctors
the nurses the pharmacists acupuncture
all of those professions um and and what
we have found in the past and one of the
reasons this this oplc was established
uh was to standardize and streamline the
application
processes uh oplc is taking that on with
the most recent uh uh addition of the
mechanical licensing board to its um
purview uh the the the uh oplc will not
be stipulating conditions of lure those
are left to the professional boards but
what this does it
streamlines uh and significantly
accelerates uh both the process for
application
relicensing uh and of course in the
instance where there may be problems
with a person uh in violation of rules
or ethics or so forth that also
standardizes the procedures between the
many boards that are under its purview
uh I've worked closely with now
executive director Courtney for about
the last three years uh working on this
bill uh it will greatly assist our
business es uh in in the Rel lier
process uh and I would ask for your
support uh for this legislation and I
thank you we'll take any
questions all right are there any
Shu thank you madam chair uh
representative GAA representative Carson
mentioned that you had also introduced
uh bill with the Financial aspects could
you tell us the number of that
bill yeah I don't recall it offand but I
can get that to you in the committee
okay thank
Schmidt thank you madam chair good
afternoon Senator
uh I certainly agree with your
assessment of the uh problems that o
oplc has gone through during its the
years of his existence it has been
plagued by numerous leadership changes
um and uh I wonder what kind of uh push
back have any you've had from the boards
or at least response you've had from the
boards in the process of your uh your
work on the on redoing everything or not
lot thank you representative for the
question question um I have not
had any P push back I've observed if you
will imaginations of numbers of boards
um that um are
perhaps uh unhappy with the fact that
standardization of procedures is coming
it must come um we have had significant
problems as an example with the nursing
board uh which uh was a significant
obstacle during the covid crisis to
getting uh licensed nurses from
jurisdictions into our state um we have
had uh uh some uh you know again
concerns
with the boards not perhaps wanting to
relinquish the administrative processes
but they're not manned they're not
they're not they don't have the
Personnel uh or the skill sets frankly
to do the administrative part of
Licensing and certification much better
done uniformly across the board uh to
the benefit both of the state and of the
of the businesses and individuals that
would make applications to them
um well if I might Madam chair so the
the house CNA also has been very
concerned over the over the years about
the situation and we have been
monitoring it as as closely as you can
without being on the other side of the
wall um so I and I don't mean the wall
between the Senate and the house I mean
the wall between the legislature and
oplc uh so uh we certainly look at your
interest thank you representative if if
I may Madam chair I I I I cannot loudly
enough sing the Praises of executive
director Courtney uh who was working as
the
assistant um and uh has done an amazing
job of correlating the many changes and
all the tentacles that flow there from
into other aspects into other areas of
Statute and collecting those things
together into this bill an enormous
amount of work very skillfully done and
and I would certainly uh I certainly
been great respector of her capabilities
and her
productivity thank you
Senator not seeing any other questions
I'll call the
you good morning Madam chair members of
the committee for the record I'm Lindsay
Courtney I am the executive director of
the New Hampshire office office of
professional Li Insurance certification
the agency that oversees the 54 boards
councils and commissions um within the
state thank you for the opportunity to
speak to you today oplc fully supports
um this bill s sp58 and wishes to thank
Senator Carson for bringing this bill
forward and to Senator GAA for his
support um with Senate Bill 13 as well
as 576 from last year over the last year
oplc has been working diligently to
establish efficiencies with within the
office in order to assist all of our
boards in their very important work this
really is just a cleanup Bill and as
such it is a crucial way to pave off it
is a crucial step to pave the way for
oplc to achieve its mission of promoting
the efficiency and economy in the
administration of its licensing boards
there are a number of objectives in this
bill um primarily though um to remove
requirement in certain practice practice
acts that require Court stenographer
uh to be present for all hearings number
two to Grant to the executive director
the authority to set PDM rates for board
members uh three we want to standardize
Quorum requirements to enable boards to
to meet and fulfill their statutory
applications we'd like to repeal RSA
332h um five at the board of veterinary
medicine which came over to us with hb4
of the last
bium um to our uh statute which is 310a
we'd like to remove references to the
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services which seems to be a
carryover um from when several of the
boards and councils were part of or
administratively attached to
DHHS remove the requirement um that
boards provide a roster of lenes for a
fee permit the agency to adopt a
retention policy across the agency
clarify that the agency itself does not
have any reporting requirements under
RSA
332g um 13 and 14 for boards that do not
fall within the agency such as
mechanical um licensing which likely
will come over but um there are boards
that are part of title
30 um Grant the executive director the
authority to promulgate rules for all
boards that participate in our
professional health program set term
limits for the board of family mediator
certification and clarify that the
executive director and not the pdmp
program administrator has certain um
statutory authority of discretionary
tasks and I do want to just go through
those briefly to just highlight the
reasons um therefore um these are not
intended to be substantive changes but
again cleanup changes that have resulted
from modifications to the various
practice acts over the years
um that um make it difficult to provide
efficiencies in the office I do want to
be clear that um the boards councils and
commissions within the office have their
own independent regulatory Authority as
you know to establish standards for
their respective profession
this bill does not propose to change
those standards or the board's authority
to set such standards and I do believe
it it does make clear that the boards
retain that Authority but there are
certain administrative functions that
are unrelated to standards of practice
that must be standardized for all boards
within the office this is really
necessary in order to ensure that we're
not creating inefficient uh
inefficiencies in the licensing process
and unnecessary unnecessary barriers uh
to Workforce entry which is a huge
problem in the state s sp58 would assist
um the intent of 310a by granting the
office the ability to streamline certain
administrative functions across all
boards making the licensing and
disciplinary processes more efficient in
terms of um the first requirement or the
first elimination that we'd like to um
to accomplish is the stenographer
requirement there are just a few
practice acts that do require a steno to
be present at a hearing this is
expensive for the agency and not not
really necessary given that we do have
the ability to record and transcribe um
at A party's expense so we'd like to
standardize this requirement across all
board and reduce the cost to the agency
by proposing to eliminate the
requirement that a stenographer be
present at hearings all boards would
just have to comply with the records
requirement in the administrative
procedures act RSA
54831 terms of the pum um this is a huge
problem for the agency there is no
standardized perdum rates sp58 proposes
to Grant to the agency the authority to
establish perdum rates for all boards
councils and commissions some boards
right now receive a perdm rate um many
do not some boards receive a perdm rate
for any work performed at any time um
this has resulted in some um some claims
for prium that are just really not
appropriate um others are required to
perform work for a certain number of
hours or
um only only receive pdms for um a for a
particular meeting um some receive a
rate of $25 others $100 I could go on
and on and on but it's very difficult
for us to effectively administer and
also to budget um so we'd like to do
this in the form of rul making by
granting the agency the authority to
establish perdum rates by um by rule
we'd also like to standardize the quum
requirements most practice Acts
established a quorum of the majority of
members appointed and confirmed by
governor and Council um but there are a
couple of practice acts that
specifically Define a set number of
board members who constitute a quorum
this becomes a problem when vacancies
are not filled um as oftentimes boards
are not able to meet conduct board
business approve applications then there
are barriers for lure as an example um
the board of hearing care providers did
not meet uh for about two years due to
lack of a quum and so licenses were
being issued and approved by operation
of law consistent with 54
a29a regardless of whether or not um
they met their requirements so obviously
that's a problem from a public safety
standpoint and we'd like to U modify the
quum
requirements um we'd also like to uh
repeal RSA 332h which requires boards to
distribute printed rules to
lenses uh frankly this is just an
outdated statutory provision uh given
that the rules are on our website which
was recently updated you may have
observed um all of our rules Now link
directly to the Gen Court website um
boards we're we're not complying with
this rule so we'd like to eliminate that
statutory
requirement um this bill also proposes
to add the board of veterinary medicine
to RSA
3101a I think that was just an oversight
in the last um Budget Trailer this bill
also proposes to remove references to
the Commissioner of Health and Human
Services specifically um Mid council is
one of them that used to be a part of
DHHS and still references um the
commissioner of
DHHS uh this bill also proposes to
eliminate the requirement of providing
rosters for a fee some practice acts
require boards to provide a roster of
lenses and to do so at a cost upon
request um however all of all of our
licensing information is available
online additionally anyone can file a
right to no request and obtain a roster
um I'll bet not with the personal
information as as determined um uh
through legal counsel but um it's the
agency's position that we really
shouldn't be charging people in excess
of what it cost to actually produce the
roster and so we'd like to eliminate
this
requirement um probably most importantly
for our current purposes um given our
recent relocation to S Eagle Square um
it's become quite obvious that we need
an agency-wide retention policy
um unfortunately we do not have that
capability at present some of the
practice acts establish a time frame in
which certain documents must be retained
other boards have already worked in the
past prior to opl's Creation with the
Secretary of State's office to adopt a
retention policy and all of these
policies conflict um so effectively the
office has been um essentially required
to maintain documents um indefinitely
which has become quite a problem from a
storage standpoint so um this bill
proposes to permit the agency to adopt a
state an agency-wide retention policy
and obviously we'd work with the boards
to determine what's what's appropriate
based on the
documents Bill also clarifies that oplc
does not have reporting requirements for
non oplc boards I could go on and on and
on about the ways that the statutes um
the statutory framework for occupational
licensing is just um probably not ideal
um one of those is the fact that not all
all of our boards are fall within title
30 um 332g is drafted in such a way that
is supposed to apply I think primarily
to the office but there are boards that
are not within the office that are part
of title 30 so we'd like to clarify that
we do not have um obligations statutory
obligations for boards that are not um
within the
office this bill also permits the agency
to adopt rules for PHP if you don't know
PHP is the professionals health program
that we contract with in order to
provide um specifically Healthcare
lienes with access to um monitoring but
also services to make sure that if they
do develop a substance use disorder that
they can get the appropriate treatment
and and possibly seek a re-entry to
Workforce um the boards presently there
are 13 of them have the ability to adopt
rules and um this has become an issue
for the vendor obviously it's difficult
to effectively administer a program with
13 sets of rules to follow so so um this
bill proposes to authorize the agency to
adopt
rules
um and then um one of the last uh
changes in this bill this very lengthy
bill um is to set term limits for the
family mediator certification board this
is really just a cleanup um because all
boards have term limits with this one
board's exception so the agency is
proposing to create term limits and
finally um this bill proposes to clarify
that uh the the executive director and
not the pdmp um State classified staff
has a discretionary Authority um to uh
perform certain functions like issue
waivers um Senator Carson did mention
the potential for an amendment if um
there was interest I have assisted um
and I have worked to draft language uh
with representative Merchants there was
concern um regarding this bill's
language that it didn't necessarily make
clear that Pharmacy inspectors in
particular must be Pharmacists and or
qualified pharmacy technicians this is
something that the agency fully supports
um and so um if the committee were so
inclined um one of the um proposed
amendments that I would recommend would
be to um offer language to make it clear
that the pharmacy inspectors must be
qualified in
Pharmacy thank you very very much for
the opportunity to provide comments I
apologize it was so lengthy um but I'm
happy to answer any questions you may
have thank you I have one question
Senator Carson mentioned that that you
added in the in the Senate Amendment
criminal background checks for
electricians I'm looking at the
electricians which is section 164 on
page
46 and it doesn't I can't see where it
calls for criminal background
checks yeah so the background checks
were requested by the board not by the
agency um and so that I think what it
the Senate did amend um fif Senate Bill
58 it's in the amendment to require
background checks for electricians this
was not part of the original Bill well
we're looking at the bill as amended by
the
Senate and I don't see any it just
says um qualifications or satisfactory
evidence of good professional character
there's nothing about criminal
background checks Madam chair I think uh
Senator GAO wants to speak on that uh
yes okay Senator GA can you answer that
question yes Madam chair and members of
the committee uh that amendment was
defeated in the Senate um and as
well respect to the the question I think
from representative Shu regarding the
fines and fees and so forth that is part
four of omnus bill Senate Bill 13 which
is which has been uh tabled by the
Senate uh so we may see that later uh as
we progress through the legislative
process act or more likely it'll be if
it's anywhere it'll be in House Bill
too representative Pearson you have a
question I do thank you madam chair and
thank you Senator guer representative
Pearson here um you you talked about
earlier in the beginning about the
policy package and the fiscal
package is that what you just mentioned
is that the fiscal package you're
talking about that was
tabled it
is representative yes um there were four
parts that ominous Bill part four was
the very lengthy similar to this bill uh
piece uh of the original one piece
legislation it was so large that we
broke it up into two one if you will the
administrative processes that uh that
executive director Courtney has spoken
to in this bill and the other one is
fees and fines and that Authority uh for
oplc and that other Bill and so uh
that's that's how the decision was made
to to uh if you will bifurcate this this
legislation and and to follow up the the
Senate chose to take that section that
was split off and combine it with other
things into an non us yes it's part of
that bill is the BET BPT
reductions um a number of
other represent okay so so Senator we're
we're looking at an axle here that's got
a a wheel on one side and a wheel on the
other and they're coming from two
different areas if one if the fiscal
package part never comes
out and we we were to go ahead with the
policy part is that going to cause a big
conundrum here with with redoing policy
without having the fiscal part of it to
go with it no I will not but I'd be
happy to uh to allow if you would
executive director Courtney to address
that it will not be problematic
thank you madam chair just a couple
quick questions for Miss gording um in
setting the perdum rates is this going
to be a one-size fits all um as we know
some boards uh pay a little more than
others and there's reasons for that um
having trouble finding people to fill
the board positions or things of that
nature um I question whether a one siiz
fits all is the right approach and is is
that what you're looking at no we're not
looking at a one-size fits-all and the
reason for that is because certain
boards meet longer meet more frequently
and frankly there's more work put into
that um I think this is going to have to
be done in consultation with the boards
we're going to have to survey to see
what you know how much time people are
actually expected to contribute um in in
being a board member one of the biggest
issues that we're facing right now
though is that certain boards um
have the ability to um receive PMS for
for any activity um that's really not
defined and has created a huge problem
fiscally for the agency we've received
some pretty uh lofty bills and um and I
I think it's just simply not because
people are acting you know
inappropriately I think it's just
because the expectations are not clear
by virtue of you know what constitutes a
predium so I think we need to to survey
the boards I think we need to understand
the time commitments um and nursing
medicine Pharmacy real estate those are
ones that put in a lot of time there are
boards that meet quarterly so obviously
they would not be be anticipated to
receive the same
prum followup follow
up then wouldn't it be in the best
interest if you're going to consult with
them to let them continue setting the
rates in consultation with you instead
of you as executive director taking
overall boards that if you're going to
consult with them they're better known
to what time frame they put in and what
they should be
paid I don't think so representative
because part of the problem that we're
running into here is that it's it's very
easy to spend other other people's money
right um and and what's happening is
that the boards by virtue of them no
longer performing the administrative
functions aren't really seeing the
impact um that some of the decisions
that they're making could have on the
agency as a whole um I I really think
that uh the agency does the budgeting
and so the agency needs to determine how
it's going to um allocate its
resources with consultation from the
boards follow up follow up uh Al got a
question about the setting the changing
the quorums I'm I'm concerned about that
as well when
um most things are in statute or in
place a quum is of those that have uh
the open not open positions included
it's of the board as a whole um I
understand the problem with a position
being left open for two years but I
guess my question is why was that left
open for two years was it because they
couldn't find anybody or because it was
just never done and whose fault is that
um I don't think we should be making
policy changes based on one in incident
um I just don't think a board members
the board position should be left open
for two
years um so how why just because of that
instance I don't understand why we
should change a quum requirement so that
was just one example representative but
actually this uh statutory change is
widely supported by the boards um who
are impacted leak is one of them leak
has a statute that sets the specific
Quorum requirement at four
notwithstanding the fact that um you
know I think they have seven board
members and I think they may have eight
board me U maybe nine um but in any
event they have a set number of board
members whereas the majority of board's
practice acts established a quorum to be
the majority of those appointed and
confirmed by governor and Council so
even if you have nine seats if you only
have seven appointed obviously your
Quorum would be four um but certain
boards aren't able to obtain a quorum
and it's not just by not being able to
fill the seat
representative there are many times
where board members um have to recuse
themselves and that poses a a quum
problem as well so this is actually a
provision widely supported by the boards
followup but if someone has to recuse
thems one or two people have to recuse
them the language is still there stating
that it's of those appointed and present
so that wouldn't change that scenario by
recusing because they'd still be present
no actually if if the if if it requires
if the statutory language like like the
statutory language that we're seeking to
change in this bill requires four for a
quorum um to make decisions you need
four you need four people who can
vote and that's the
problem
I think I think that the question was if
there are seven members appointed but
two of them have recused themselves is
the Quorum still
for
yesk thank you do it give talks about
Shu thank you madam chair um I'm not
sure if this is
a question for Miss Courtney or actually
for uh you madam chair or perhaps
representative Schmidt I see several
different areas in the bill uh and the
final phrase in that section is
something of the nature consistent with
the retention policy established by the
oplc um who's going to oversee the
policy that oplc establishes is that
something that would be uh Incorporated
by administrative rules or who would you
get approval of I mean just you're just
going to be the executive director and
king or queen and this is the way it's
determined yeah so agencies in order to
adopt um I mean theyd have to we'd have
to engage in Ru making and traditionally
retention policies also have to be
approved by the Secretary of State's
office so um so that's how we would go
process you're saying that the retention
policy will be an agency policy and it
is reviewed and approved by the
Secretary of State correct um just to
make sure it's appropriate so for
example we may have one um rule
pertaining to disciplinary files how
long you have to keep a disciplinary
file you may have a rule R pertaining to
lure files as it stands we have boards
that have approved retention policies
for the same types of files that are
vastly different um some boards have
stated that you need to keep
disciplinary files forever some have
stated that you only need to keep um
certain portions of a disciplinary file
forever some say only seven years I I
think you can appreciate that it's it's
very difficult for us to
administratively um support different
retention policies 54 different
retention policies particularly we have
66 question question
um that as an example I wasn't referring
specifically to hential although that is
one of the areas but there are several
other things
um that's that basically just reverts
back to we're going to tell you this is
what you have to do and that's my
concern um and I don't know for example
with the retention does there need to be
uh a site to approval by the Secretary
of State's office or some of these other
statements
um there need to be a site to a
Consulting Authority or
whatever so the language as drafted
grants the office the authority to
establish um
policies through this retention
basically retention schedule through
rulemaking I believe representative and
I could I believe having researched this
about a year ago that there is another
statute that sets forth what state
agencies and public bodies have to do in
order to approve or Implement a
retention schedule and it's specif so I
so obviously we would be expected to
comply with that statute as well but um
I will do that res search and and follow
up with you after that um because I just
don't know the statutory citation off
the top of my head okay followup Madam
chair follow up as I said I wasn't
referring only to retention I see
another one uh talking about an
applicant for
registration um so on and so forth using
the method prescribed and furnished by
the office of oplc uh so like I said
there are several different sites in
here that basically reverts the policy
decision back to the head off rather
than the individual
board yeah yeah and that's purposeful um
you know if I may just briefly explain
what's going on in the office my
assessment is that the reason the agency
hasn't
really aside from probably ineffective
leadership hasn't uh been been able to
really do what it's been asked to do in
terms of promote efficiencies is because
it hasn't had the authority to adopt
procedures and streamlined application
processes across the board I'm not
talking about standards I'm not talking
about criteria as to you know what
somebody needs to accomplish in order to
obtain a license as a nurse we've got 54
boards councils and commissions um most
of them have many different licensing
types and we've got to effectively
administer
uh hundreds of different forms um
hundreds of different workflow and
processes with 66 full-time people uh
that just doesn't work and we've seen
that and that's one of the reasons why
the way occupational licensing is set up
in the state it's a barrier it's a
barrier to Workforce entry just based on
the process not the standards so I think
that we really need to standardize and
streamline and I think that's what 310a
was intended to accomplish by giving
oplc that Authority but unfortunately
when oplc did obtain that Authority and
I do believe we do have the authority to
adopt streamlined procedures there
remain statutory Provisions that don't
allow us to effectuate that intent and
these are the statutory Provisions for
example when we say um you know in the
bill
um they have to follow the procedures
and that were established by the office
of professional Li Insurance
certification that's a procedure process
doesn't affect the substance but we do
need one process to follow otherwise
we're never going to be competitive um
with other states in terms of
Occupational licensing and um it's
you're going to continue to see the
turnover in the agency because it's just
not an effective way um to to administer
state government just my opinion and I'm
off on a tangent but that's just that's
the intent of this
Bill thank
you representative
Schmidt
thank you madam chair so
uh what youve been talking about Miss
Courtney
is the kind of thing that I think some
of us senior members of the of house
Edna have been wrestling with or at
least pondering for years believing that
the structure of oplc is
dysfunctional uh is just not designed to
work
um or the way it is designed it can't
work anyway so there there's some of
these some aspects of this bill that are
pretty straightforward that I think we
can probably agree on some of the other
stuff I think we're going to have to
wrestle with I'm wondering um have you
prioritized uh the various components of
of the bill uh with regard to that
specific aspect that I've just
discussed
yeah I mean certain things are are um
higher priorities than others um I would
say PDM is pretty top of the list
because it's blowing our budget um as
soon as we run out of money you know I
had somebody submit a bill the other day
for
$8,000 as soon as the money's gone the
money's gone and I legally can't spend
it so um so I think that's a high
priority um but the other thing um that
I think is a high priority is the quum
requirement I think because that really
impacts lure honestly doesn't have an
impact to oplc as an agency um we
observed that this was a problem for the
boards and the boards supported this
change with the Quorum requirements
because they're not able to to timely
license people all the time because they
can't obtain a quorum and I agree with
representative goal that in an Ideal
World all seats would be filled all the
time um we've we we do our best um to
try to obtain uh qualified candidates
obviously it's not up to the agency to
appoint them um the governor's office
typically nominates
um but I have great relationship with a
lot of professional associations but you
know we've got a Midwifery council with
I think seven people on it and only 30
lenses so at some point everybody who's
a l is going to cycle through that
Council that it makes it difficult I
think to to find Qualified people who
are willing to to give up their time so
that obviously would also be a priority
and then um certainly the um the
retention policy is a big priority we
just have so much paper we are doing our
best right now to um scan everything in
um hopefully with hb2 we've proposed um
not hb2 but um hb1 we've proposed and
the governor has supported and the house
has supported thus far um our ability to
um spend funds for an electronic record
keeping system a document management
system that will help um but we have
documents going back to the 30s that are
just in boxes and storage all over the
place we're really trying to get our
hands around this issue um we've
developed naming conventions we've um
scanning things in we're trying our best
not to accept paper documents but but
this goes back to the authority of what
the different statutes and the rules
look like um to me I look at that as a
procedure should should a board be able
to dictate that we have to accept paper
or can the agency adopt you know an
online um portal process which would
which is consistent with what other
states have across the country um but if
you allow boards to pick and choose how
they're going to accept applications not
the content of the applications but how
they're going to accept it we're going
to end up um with the process that we
have which is that we just have to
accept everything in perpetuity so that
is a huge um problem for us right now is
the retention policy we do have um we
have been working as part of the grant
that we received through the Department
of Labor we had contracted with clear um
to conduct an analysis of certain
licensing categories um for the boards
but we had amended that scope to conduct
an analysis of the umbrella agencies as
a whole um I don't yet have that
analysis or that report I suspect I will
have that next week but I do have the
survey that was conducted um and over
70% of the 23 umbrella agencies across
the country responded and I can provide
that to the committee um because it just
may be um helpful um to have that data
and that information as to what other
states have
done follow up follow
up so I think this is frankly very
useful because we've got a lot of new
members on this committee who haven't
had to deal with any of this craziness
uh I I've been on for 15 years and and
and uh oplc actually I think has been
around more than the seeven six or seven
years that Senator guer referenced I
think it's more like 10 years um but uh
it the the Quorum issue is one that you
you've uh emphasized here uh do you
recall it may have been before you came
on board we had a quorum situation A
couple of years ago where we shortened
the Quorum requirements it the this has
to be a problem Nationwide I would think
uh so is there is there some kind of a
workaround because this this committee
can't function without a quorum it's not
legal and I recognize that somebody who
was recused um doesn't count uh so uh
there there has to be some kind of an
alternative uh have you explored that
aspect with regard to the Corum situ
which is crucial I agree with you yeah I
I think what we've observed within the
agency is that the boards that have a
quum um that is simply the majority of
those appointed by governor and Council
don't typically run into Quorum problems
It's usually the boards that have a
specific number of people um like for
example Hearing Care Providers their
Quorum is four they only have four
people can you can you repeat the the
name again you got by me too fast yeah
Hearing Care Providers is hearing okay
thank you uh leak is another one right I
believe psych psychology may be one as
well there are several um that are in
this bill that have a specific set
number regardless of how many people
have actually filled the
slots okay well
unfortunately this frankly needs a
subcommittee but we can't do
subcommittees during the pandemic but we
we've got to sit down and and knock out
uh individual aspects of this that
because you're you're literally trying
you I'm sure you're familiar with the
the pl the jugglers and plate Spinners
you've just got too many plates to spin
as you know in Your Capacity um so thank
you representative
goalie thank you madam chair just a
quick question uh regarding uh you made
a comment just a few minutes ago about
some of these changes to be made to be
competitive with other states can you
elaborate a little bit about what you
meant by
that yeah I mean we're losing Workforce
to Vermont Massachusetts Maine um when I
talk to people seeking lure it's often
times um you know they make comments to
the effect of oh well I was able to get
a license um from Vermont in 24 hours
that is their policy um but it takes it
takes like the board of mental health
practice for example 60 days
um for to issue a license and so I got a
job offer in Vermont and so I'm going to
Vermont and that um data became very
clear um when the pandemic hit um by
virtue of the governor issuing an
emergency order authorizing the office
not the boards to issue emergency orders
and I was very surprised because I I
fully anticipated I was the one manually
issuing the licenses I expected them to
be all Physicians and nurses it was
mostly mental health providers and a lot
of of them actually lived in New
Hampshire they just didn't have a New
Hampshire license because they were
working in another state um and when I
talk to a lenes and when I talk to
Providers along the border um one of the
biggest um hurdles that I have heard
about regardless of whether or not you
know perception is everything is that
New Hampshire is slow for lure and just
the time frame alone not the content the
time frame as it relates to other states
if we
slow um we're going to lose those those
applicants to other states that's what I
mean by competitive in the process not
the content but the
process followup follow
up so
under current practice license share
goes through the boards and under the
executive order can you tell me how are
you issuing the licenses just by getting
information or is it still going the
board still part of the process the
boards are part of the permanent lure
process the emergency order specifically
authorize the agency not the boards to
issue emergency licenses with provided
certain criteria were established and
that includes having a license in a in
another jurisdiction that's in good
standing so that's that's the only
criteria that we're looking at and today
I think we've issued about 25,000
emergency
licenses um honestly the uh complaints
that I've received have drastically
declined since March because people are
able to get an immediate temporary
license while they pursue the permanent
application
process and that is that
followup is that the direction we're
looking to go is issue Temporaries until
they can go through full lure and for a
permanent solution here in New Hampshire
yeah we already have that um there was a
statutory change to
310a um last year I think I forget which
bill was tacked on to at the very end an
Omnibus Bill but after the state of
emergency ends it granted oplc the
authority to issue temporary licenses
for a period of up to 120 days um
provided that the individual has a
license in another
jurisdiction um and I think it makes
sense if you have a license in another
jurisdiction that's in good standing
you're most likely qualified and you
have been working you're most likely
qualified um to work um in terms of risk
benefit analysis does it make sense to
make those individuals uh wait months on
end to obtain a license probably not and
I think that's been reflected in the
general Court's um work with the 330 uh
332g regarding reciprocity and other
statements regarding temp
lure thank
br thank
you comparing um the structure that
how would it compare to the structure
that's being used for
similar offices in other states that are
Hampshire so um in the report that I can
Ser I can provide you has some states
have released their organizational
charts um the structure in terms of
organizationally that's an hb2 that's
very consistent with the structure and
other offices um a large um a decent
number of umbrella agencies their boards
like Vermont their boards are advisory
boards which is very different obviously
than what we have in New Hampshire um
New Hampshire is the only state that has
an umbrella agency that and that has
policy autonomous boards that do not
have someone or some oversight over the
policies established by the boards um
and many states uh the agency um has
sort of like veto Authority in other
states there's a legislative committee
and other states it's the governor um so
we do have four advisory boards in the
office right now um but that's that's
obviously a slight minority that's not
what we're proposing by virtue of this
legislation but but just globally that's
how umbrella agencies are typically
operating across the
country so there isn't anybody that's
um well it depends on the function that
we're talking about there are 23
umbrella agencies across the country and
there are certain aspects of what we do
um that are very similar to other boards
by and large um umbrella agencies do
have the authority to adab to adopt
procedures application processes
contract for applications software and
that's what we should have in New
Hampshire um I think that's what the
intent is in 310a we haven't been able
to implement it because of the statutory
barriers that are reflected in
sp58 um if we're talking about globally
Authority that's a conversation that I
think the state needs to have doesn't
need to have in the context of sp58 but
um that's that that is very different
from what other states I think
chair if we if this implemented what
type
of it doesn't seem to me that some of
the boards are going to
be uh satisfied with
this so how are you going to handle the
conflicts there really isn't anything in
sp58 that I think is controversial and
um I do have a very good working
relationship with the large majority of
boards we don't always agree um but
that's okay um we're all willing to come
to the table and figure it out um and
just the other day I was speaking to the
Board of Medicine specifically regarding
the retention issues because they were
concerned they they rely heavily on
their investigative materials and I you
know we worked it through and you know
we're going to um establish a working
group um my intent is not to come on
come in here and not work with people
and establish rules that are just non-w
workable we have to work with each other
I have 350 board members that I have to
get along with
but I have noticed that there are just
certain barriers to getting anything
done uh for anybody and that doesn't
help any of the boards so um I don't
believe it will be a problem um to work
with the boards and actually I don't see
anything within this legislation that is
uh really remotely controversial the
steno requirement is a problem for us
because we have to pay money and often
times we forget we forget which board
has the center requirement the prum is
an issue because certain boards feel
like they should get one and other
boards get one and maybe shouldn't get
one um for that particular activity hor
requirements it it hurts the boards they
can't conduct their business um you know
adding the board to the veterinary
medicine to our statute that's just
that's not substantive the roster
requirement I mean that's that's
difficult because you know it it can be
difficult to manage okay who has a
roster and and why do we charge them a
100 bucks versus okay this is just
something they should the public should
be entitled to pursuing to
91a um you know the PHP rules that's
something that we desperately need um
but uh our vendor we haven't been able
to adopt them so I'm not seeing anything
in here um unless there's somebody on
the family mediator certification board
that wants to serve for you know in
perpetuity that is
controversial thank
you are there any other
questions
right seeing none thank you very much
thank you very much is there anyone else
uh yes P them in a
speak
just unmute yourself Miss
Maham thank you madam chair can you hear
me yes thank you very much um for the
record Paula minihan Senior vice
president state government relations
with the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all the
hospitals in the state we are in strong
support of Senate Bill 58 I did submit
um brief testimony um so I won't read
that but I am in again our hospitals
work with many many of the clinical
boards as you can imagine um under
oplc and we have worked um for years to
try to address some of the concerns that
I believe are being addressed in Senate
Bill 58 as outlined very succinctly and
um clearly by um executive director
Courtney as well as Senator GAA and
Senator Carson um all those issues that
she was outlining um our um VPS and
directors of HR deal with all the time
and have asked um Lindsay for help
throughout the years to try to
streamline these Quorum issues have
caused true true problems with
individuals not getting a license and
not being able to practice in the state
of New Hampshire and um just the mere
reason is because they don't have a
quorum to have a board meeting and we
would show up at the just to find out
that there is no meeting because they
the folks were busy because they're
clinici misss and they can't leave their
offices so I just wanted to reiterate
again how important this streamlining is
um I know that this is a big change but
so was I I was I was here when oplc was
created and as as executive director
Courtney indicated that it never really
I mean that was established but but we
have not really streamlined um
appropriate protocols and and processes
to make it actually function properly um
so I just wanted to um I'm I I'm happy
to answer any questions but really I
just wanted to um let you know that the
hospitals are very supportive of this
effort and um and we encourage you to um
to pass the bill that's it thank
you thank
you representative fellow you have a
question yes thank you um for Paula um
can you tell me can you tell us which
boards those were that were having the
problem that you witnessed because I'm
I'm sure you weren't going to see all 54
boards so correct thank you
representative for the question so of
course um the hospitals focus on the
clinical boards I don't have the list of
boards in front of me but I think there
are 20 some odd clinical boards um and
they run the gamut of um all the Mental
Health Professions Allied professions
which is an Allied board but it has ptot
speech um I feel like I'm forgetting a
couple um the med tech registry they
deal with they deal with the medical
imaging radiation technology board is
one of the newer boards that has we've
had some um issues getting those rules
um set up and again because the rules
weren't didn't have a quorum they
couldn't finalize rules and it went on
for a really long time um we um I'm
trying to think I obviously Board of
Nursing they deal with Board of Medicine
they deal with um I again I don't have I
mean there are probably a dozen or so
boards that they that the hospitals um
work with and assist um in getting their
clinicians
licensed so I don't think that was a
them followup yes followup yeah so just
I'm just trying to be clear so you're
saying that it are you telling us that
it's almost every board you deal with
has this has had this issue and it's not
just two or three or four boards that
you deal
with so what I think Executive Director
Courtney was trying to outline is that
because of the variation from board to
board and the Quorum issues um for one
example and then the proo the processes
that they go through they vary from
board to board and so it's it's hard for
a Hospital HR person that is um has so
many employees that they're trying to
get licensed because effectively every
clinician that works on in a hospital
has to be licensed or certified um or
registered under in the state of New
Hampshire which is important for patient
safety um because each board has their
own processes and there is not
uniformity we find that there is
inefficiencies in that and it's
difficult for the HR folks to
follow what the requirements are for the
various boards and that that's really my
point I was not saying I was not naming
all the issues that we have with the
boards but the mirt and med tech are two
that I personally have been involved in
through the last three or four years
that I have witnessed has been a
challenge um but I think it's just um an
indication of again separate boards
separate processes and inefficiencies
are result result from that I think the
behavioral health uh Mental Health Board
has um we've had a lot of issues
throughout the years with that board as
well because again um delays in um in
getting licensed and um what executive
director Courtney indicated is a real
concern to the um Health Care Providers
relative to losing clinicians because
they can't get license quickly in the
state of New Hampshire um and and one
issue had to do with the criminal
background check process which is not
opl's responsibility but the department
of safety has certainly um sped that
process up by by creating their portal
which is very very helpful um but we
just yeah I was I was actually asking
specifically
about the the boards and the the Quorum
so
I can't I I am not probably um I mean
I'd have to go through every single
board rules to see what their Quorum
requirements are but I can just I'm just
asking about your ex your experience so
did right you've
experienced like trying to go to a
meeting and there's no Quorum there and
I'm just wondering if Zoom if they were
doing meetings via Zoom if that
would partly eliminate that issue make
it a lot easier for everybody the
meeting not right and I um I'm not sure
of the answer to that but absolutely I
have shown up at
oplc just to find out because the board
members are also practicing clinicians
they are unable to um
participate they cannot have they did
not have a quorum for whatever the
requirements were so they couldn't hold
the meeting which delayed finalizing
some licenses that okay I experience
that thank thank you for that
information you're welcome
representative Schmid do you have a
question this
time I always have a question Madam
chair I
sometimes please ask 15 your M A 158
year member of this committee I have
some right to be heard so I object
you're muting me you can discipline me
but not muting me is is not allowed so
in any case uh M Miss cour Mr Courtney
uh how much has the pandemic uh
complicated this
situation um representative Schmidt this
is Paul in aan is the question for me
I'm the clinician issue that you've
addressed obviously is a crucial one but
how much is the pandemic uh uh made it
worse and then as uh representative
fellows was just asking how much has the
zoom Al alternative made some things
more
viable um I would say the pandemic has
led to many many concerns um and and
delays um throughout the um Hospital
industry and and certainly trying to get
um um addressing a lot of issues but the
temporary licensure process that was um
initiated with the emergency order that
that executive director Courtney
outlined has actually made a tremendous
um difference and we actually were
involved in and working with her and um
to get that established and we were very
supportive of that so that has been
helpful um I would say zoom in general
um makes it easier you know easier for
people to testify at hearings like this
and easier for people to attend board
meetings no question I'm I'm sure of
that okay followup so it one of the
things is that the governor has issued a
lot of emergency orders in view of the
pandemic has he been uh engaged with
regard to trying to um resolve some of
these
issues I I'm sorry I'm not clear I don't
think I I understand your question um
what very interesting question but I do
not believe Miss menahan is the proper
person to ask it of well she is she is
certainly involved with the medical
professions which is one of the most
crucial aspects here so I'm just
wondering how much the the hospital
Association has tried to engage with the
governor with regard to Expediting some
things because the legal process and the
legislative process are two separate
things and the and the legislative
process is notoriously slow and the
governor's executive Authority is
certainly faster and I'm wondering how
much you guys have appealed to the
governor for some relief if you see a
direction I there are so many executive
or uh emergency orders I I'm not I can
just address I'll I I don't know that I
can truly answer the question but like
tella Health that was an emergency order
that was issued early on it was number
eight so um that was very early on and
that made a was a tremendous help as I
think you all know um for um as the
pandemic um hit and everything closed
down so quickly so that's a good example
of an import an emergency order that has
been very helpful and the legislature
fortunately agreed and um promulgated uh
excuse me um
implemented um the the statute um to
make it permanent last year um so that
that has been EX extremely beneficial
and welcome um so that's an example I
I'm not sure that I can um add anything
more to to that answer no you've already
you've already answered my question the
way you
go thank you madam chair thank you Paul
for taking my question um just a quick
question on some of these boards that
you talked about that didn't have
quorums um you St that because of time
commitments or work conditions or
whatever that people did not
attend um was it because of vacancies
that there wasn't a quum on the board or
did they have a h full uh was their
board filled up at the time with uh
those permitted
slots um I'm not 100% sure
representative goalie um what the
circumstances were um because again they
vary and I can't recall which which
exact because I attend a lot of board
meetings so I can't remember exactly
which board it was but it has happened
um that they did not have a quorum um
honest just a quick followup so this may
not this bill may
not solve all the problems out there if
there's some boards that are full still
correct I think the issue with
having that particular number what um
does does impact um their ability I do
recall that happening once that they
needed four I remember that number
specifically and um they didn't have
four so I I don't know um I don't know
but um but as as Lindsay did indicate um
when we find out that there and that was
a new um procedure implemented by by
executive director Courtney when um
there are openings in on a board we are
made aware as our other um stakeholder
organizations to try and
recruit um if there's a nurse needed or
a med tech needed um a a radiologist
needed um we are made aware along with
the medical society and the Board of
Nursing H excuse not the board of the
Nurses Association Etc so that we can
try and help to recruit individuals um
so that we have a procedure now that was
not in place before so I think that is
actually has really helped um to to
stimulate some interest um to be on a
board and to go through that process so
that that has been actually very
helpful thank you
you
oops
representative fellows you're muted did
you have a
question thank you my question has to do
with the hospitals that you represent so
when they have one of these issues that
you were just talking about you know
hire and there seems to be a delay do
you know anything about the procedure
that they use for for contacting the
state to move this forward do they call
is do they have a particular person that
they that they call um at the OPC or how
does that
work
um Lindsay Courtney has offered to
assist so she usually just um has them
call her um and and she looks into the
issue works with the administrator for
the various boards um to to the the
appropriate board to find out what the
delay is and someone gets back to the HR
person um to try to um eliminate
whatever delay whatever the cause of the
delay is if they're missing information
whatever it is um so actually um Lynsay
has off has provided her contact
information and that's typically what
information
all right is there anyone else who
hand and Miss Courtney while we're
thinking about it could you you said you
issued about 25,000 temporary licenses
if you could give us a breakdown by
which board I would very much appreciate
it
I I don't think she's been here for like
seven or eight minutes at
least okay in that case I'll I'll deal
with her on my own all right no one else
has raised their hand so I will close
the public
represent yes represent
fellow yes can um was not aware that
they moved to Eagle Square do did anyone
else know that or why they moved they we
were notified months ago but so you just
missed
it why did they move because someone
else wanted that the uh the building
they were in and it was more appropriate
to be closer to other
facilities exactly okay because I know
where the building was I you that where
I knew where they were so they moved 66
plus people to Eagle Square rented
facility
yes yes plus boxes and boxes and boxes
of
paper uh representative Schmidt thank
you for that information I would also
like to say that I have muted you
exactly once when you were trying to
make speeches in a public hearing I'm
not trying to make speeches Madam chair
I'm trying to have a dialogue one of the
things is and you know what it's like
you've been on this committee for a long
time that that how important
subcommittees are and we're we're
operating with one hand tied behind our
back without the ability to make to
working subcommittees I don't I don't
dispute that we don't have enough staff
to do it but it's it we're we're we're
hopping in a race where everybody else
is
running yes thank you I was however
rather hurt when you implied that I was
was in the practice of muting you no no
I said I didn't say you're doing it all
the time I never said anything except
that's not quite kosher you can call me
down but anyway the bottom line is we
need to work on this this is a
desperately important situation you know
that because you've been around for a
while and you you understand all of this
and those of us who've been here for a
while we also know that this is a very
dysfunctional Agency for various reasons
it was badly designed the beginning and
the the failure leadership I think that
Miss Courtney is doing a great job
wrestling with this but she is also uh
trying to spin too many plates
simultaneously and the Quorum situation
you can imagine what it would be like if
we didn't have a quum to exec all our
bills we'd be handy we'd be helpl us
thank you I appreciate that I'm going to
give you my policy on muting if I call
someone's name three times and they
still keep talking then I'll mute them
okay okay it's just that I haven't
complained about it before but I I did
this time because I'm trying to have a
dialogue where we can't have a
subcommittee and and Lindsay is doing
her damn this and I I I think she she's
got she's gotten a lot of Praise from
people okay uh represent you like to
have a subcommittee meeting we we can
standle one we have we have almost a
month before we have to EXA this
bill okay well I think that would
helpful be helpful because we have to
have a dialogue and the question and
answer format of a hearing is not that
functional with regard to some of these
issues where we got to go back and forth
so let's have a subcommittee we've got
enough experienced people to to put
together people who don't have to you
know find out what's going on before
they can make decisions I agreed with
you we're I'll schedule a committee
meeting
okay great good representative has a
has a comment or a
question thank you madam chair you just
answered my uh question and concern as
to whether or not we're gonna have a
subcommittee on this Bill thank you okay
we will have a
subcommittee
representative subcommittee huh uh this
has been looked at for three years now I
even heard a single thing that was
substantive this is a technical
correction and you I guess I have why
not have a subcommittee I suppose but
nobody put their finger on any specific
anything it was just general concern but
nobody could say where it was hurting so
if this what's the subcommittee going to
do but be generally suspicious so I I
trust the three years of work that's
been done on the bill representative
goalie thank you madam chair if I could
just respond to represent
sitech uh we received an approximately
70 page Bill last year uh and an Omnibus
package um that we could not have a full
hearing on um and so we did not vet this
fully over the last two years from what
I
saw it's been worked in the Senate
that's not quite the
same sure I I have several suggestions
but uh but but it's not appropriate to
make them in in a hearing
correct all right we will we will I will
meeting and I think at this point we
will adjourn for the day since we've had
our public hearing next Wednesday we
have a hearing on an Omnibus on
licensing I will try to do it section by
section and uh I hope that we will ask
we will all read the bill prior to the
hearing That's My
Hope thank you all and good night thank
you thank